attending our budget.
Subcommittee six. Homelessness.
Really appreciate everybody for
coming- we also appreciate
minor Marylander breed tending
to the I know she had a very
tight time frame so we were
going to give her the opening
statement and then proceed on
the hearing so memory. Well
first of all- thank you
assembly member taking for- not
only provided me with this
opportunity but also for your
incredible advocacy on
homelessness and housing and
the work that you continue to
do- to leverage resources not
only first Francisco but your
your understanding of the-
complexities of the issue and
our need. To do more on the
state level you've been a great
advocate and we really
appreciate that- thank you to
members of the committee- thank
you to my assembly member David
Chiu it's really great to be
here and thank you also again
for- hosting this- hearing here
in San Francisco which has.
Definitely made it more
convenient. For me out by- so
good morning everyone times
London for the mayor of San
Francisco and- as we all know
we've we've seen- throughout
not only San Francisco but
throughout the state-
homelessness is really taken
front and center and has-
played itself out on our
streets in a way that- is
something that as a- San
Franciscan it as- San
Francisco. And as someone seen
homelessness- over the years to
this magnitude not to since it.
Is including an oak I know may
shaft is here to test as well-
it is it is like nothing I've
ever seen before. In San
Francisco alone we have over a
thousand people experiencing
homelessness on any given night
and five thousand people are
less. On shelter. It's every
night San Francisco provide
shelter and housing to over
thirteen thousand people and we
have more permanent supportive
housing per capita than any
other major city in the United
States and still are citizens
are suffering. In fact over the
past. Years. Sit homelessness
and it doesn't even look like
we scratch the surface. Every
day when I walked the streets
of the city I witnessed the
suffering even on my way here
to this hearing. The families
hustling from the bus stops to
the shelter the young adults
force to set up a tent on the
sidewalk the veteran struggling
to hold on to their dignity. It
is really been challenging to
witness and frustrating not to
be able to move faster to deal
with this crisis. I'm really
grateful again for this
committee and their leadership
dedicating new state resources
over the past two budget
cycles. Cities and counties can
not address this crisis alone
we need to work in partnership
with the state to allocate the
funding recall. Tied on prices
and I'm also grateful to the
governor leadership on this
issue. Twenty twenty. Twenty
two. Twenty twenty one.
Included unprecedented amount
of state funding. As
homelessness San Fran Cisco has
received over twenty seven
million dollars and he funding
and we have invested those
resources in rapid housing for
transitional age you an adult
and in the capital and operate
a- and- versions. To help get
people on the housing San
Francisco will likely receive
eight million dollars in a H.
A. P. funding this year and we
plan to use those resources to
continue to expand our recent
centers and it proved.
Transcriptions access child.
Third round of my money is
appreciated would certainly go
to get you over on going
funding is not Terry to make a
meaningful impact in the lives
of people on the streets in
this ongoing funding will allow
the cities and counties across
the state to continue the
programs opened with- the both
he and happy funding
additionally. Funding will
allow community vast in the
most effective interview and
that is. House without said
later more rocker see an by
passing cities and counties as
outlined in the current
proposal is counterproductive.
Cities and counties are
primarily response the building
employs operate. Respond state
resort is to calm and local and
federal funding I encourage the
sub committee to re commit to
requiring that from the state
be provided to local
jurisdictions. And this will in
short in use. From programs
that have been six. The good
must are says to mandate is the
most notable which is the legal
mandate to require local
governments to commit resources
to dramatically with
homelessness in our communities
and I support the goals of this
mandate and I see that every.
Jurisdiction has to do their
part across this this state to
help address this issue I also
saw the need for increased
accountability to ensure that
our limited resources are spent
effectively however. I cannot
support the constitution
amendment as currently proposed
because then you requirements
placed on local government
would not come with the needed
resources to actually implement
them- so. That's my two cents I
wanna again thank you all so
much for working with my office
during this budget process- to
help us address these issues- I
know that this is a very
challenging issue and have a
lot of great players with.
Great ideas and a lot of people
who are working hard. To
address this issue and really
proud of what we've done in San
Francisco but of course we need
more and we're hoping that
you'll continue to work with us
to accomplish the goals that we
all want to see and that is
putting. An end to homelessness
and our state thank you. Thank
you thank you and we will
should all. For on this issue
I've ever since you've been a
dish supervisors as mayor this
is been one of your- top
priorities and shows and
everything that you've been
doing in terms of your budget.
And in terms of the policy work
you've been doing on top of-
being advocate for housing we
knew it we know that that's a
huge part of the equation. I
know that- you don't have time
for questions so I know Mister
Kaczynski was here for the
later part of the day I'll bet
thank you but yes I mean that
that's what we're taught if you
wanted to. Take a question to
one of my- colleagues had. Not
I think not at this time it was
just getting warmed up things
are really really appreciate
your coming by today and just
kicking off our hearing thank
you gray and thank you so much
for the opportunity and thank
you to everyone here today I to
help us address this issue- we
gotta get started we got to
move faster. You can change in
an- for to help us do that
again thank you. A so that
we're gonna continue with our
hearing- again we are having a
overview of the state
homelessness funding in the
governor's budget proposal on
how this- we know that at this
point in our state we have. A
homelessness crisis- with over
a hundred and fifty one
thousand Californians who are
on our street- we have about
nine thousand and- plus
homeless individuals in San
Francisco. LA que just finish
the this not. John San
Francisco or Los Angeles or
from I'm really appreciate I
called again for being here
from Bakersfield this is an
issue that. Into the Senate the
only issue that really. Huge
number of home. All up in the-
all the leadership that we able
to work with governor brown as
well governor knew some of the
state over the last two years
has specifically done. One
point one billion dollars of
funding to. Focus on
homelessness that was. Counties
que the continuum of care which
is a variety of nonprofit
networks it in counties who
really have been fighting and
what on this issue of
homelessness for the last few
decades we know that we need to
do more- but just to put this
in context is a huge jump from
really where the state used to
do. The state we have not. Hey
did in housing or hopelessness.
It up till the last few. Really
the state have abdicated their
ability the main the funding
for housing was our low income
housing tax credit. He had. All
all fired a few years ago. Even
that funding to make sure that
program was further further
funded as well as to it for
that we now are finding the
area of homelessness. Yeah and-
I've had the doctor of really
working years ago really
working with our- mers to bring
this. To for we know that. Many
others are as my mayor talked
about the all the mayors they
feel like they're really at
ground zero of this issue. Any
exit don't those types of
resort. Today as part our
hearing we have represent from
the ministry Papa the new
proposal we also have
representatives we have. Three
three of the big city mayors
well as represent us in LA
county and also- really a-
professor from UCSF more.
Senator from whatever is on the
cutting edge of homelessness
but but today we wanted to make
sure that this hearing was held
in San Francisco in the bay
area where we have really felt
the crux of this issue for some
years- now that it's really
gotten to be done. Across the
state. The state now decided to
call partner in working to
eradicate business in
California. We we're proud to
have the world's fifth largest.
The same time we want people
living in poverty those that's
one in five way too many at the
same time that the economy is
booming for some we have so
many families indeed it. Can't
the most be. The life they
can't afford to buy food can't
afford to pay rent they can't
afford to purchase gas for
their vehicle to get to. And so
we know. What are we doing make.
Some of the middle class
working class Californians and
so again this is it this
funding is a key piece of
proposal really honor to have a
number of my colleagues- join
me today for our- open it to
them. If they have a- remarks.
But for those that know me as a
member Vince Fong represent the
such about Kern county- but
certainly I want to thank a
charge for the in my- in a you
know when we do we talk about
housing and cal you know a lot
of folks will think of the- in
the center valley in and rural
communities yeah but we have a
crisis as well and so for
myself I only. Have delved
into. Q. certainly will look
for working with the guy.
Ministry well as a- I'm not.
Right away the with the system
as a whole certainly a lot of
the attention goes to shelters
and shelter heads- but you know
we did a we utilizing
collecting. The at them she's
will get. You know using a to
my sister. Most and we do
assessment of individuals on
the streets but no all we are
we Atty using that- because
that that information is near
real time as opposed to the
point time can't which I
participated in this year in I
in my community. And certainly
you know where the gaps- in are
we investing in a doing enough
on that's what. I'm and are we
investing enough in support
housing so those are the areas
that I certainly want to- desk
and learn from but certainly
this is a this is that not
only. Exists in urban centers
by in the real centers as well
so thank you very much. Strict
fifty into a one of a begin
thanking Kerr. A chair ting for
always said taking opportunity
to plug cut- the bear so. Go
bears- our our- mutual- water.
This is an extremely serious
issue it's one that's been
going on- in California for far
too long- I personally have
been- a working on homeless
issues for now over twenty
years and- is the mayor of
Santa Monica and- for a short
period of time is executive
director of a homeless
nonprofit- for so it's quite
to. Sync up for all of us- to
be here today after working on
this issue for so long and
seeing the numbers- a
dramatically higher than they
were of a few years ago but
that number in southern
California or even- in the
state of a hundred and- fifty
thousand plus. Most people who
are here- the fifty eight
thousand are counted in Los
Angeles county and I was. Out
on the streets Santa Monica- as
part of the count- this year
and every year since we started
counting and number years ago-
but that- number doesn't tell
the whole story- in Los Angeles
county- free is allowed to the-
new. Yes P. died on the street
each of the- years it's
outrageous- it's outrageous
particularly when we- recognize
that were actually housing.
Where people than ever before
you would think we'd be
reducing those numbers and
catching up but- we're doing
good. And in regard not well
enough but we're doing better-
but the problem that we face
today. Is that more people are
entering homelessness than are
leaving in Los Angeles county-
around a hundred and fifty
three people a day. Are being
housed- but a significantly
higher number are entering
homelessness on a daily basis
and that's that delta that's
creating the- the statistic
where we see a right. Number of
people in three will but we
need to do about it we also
know- what the solutions are
ultimately permanent supportive
housing- is the gold standard
we need to build more we need
to provide that housing. But we
also need to do more to prevent
people from entering
homelessness in the first
place- as rental subsidies- and
other. Energy out there we need
to recognize that there are. A
number of factors at play and
why people are- ended up home
this this is not just one. One
thing their social factors like
of dental health issue that are
up the priest. Up close the
biggest have. Dress the a we
have a napa. Of math this. With
no really good solutions that
are taking a number of lives
and destroying lives on a daily
basis- throughout throughout
the state so I'm really anxious
to hear from the administration
understand better- the
governor's proposal- I have for
us some thoughts on that but
all reserve the- for later.
Thank you. Morning I'm David
Chiu N. as the assembly member
representing the district were
in I want to welcome all of you
to San Francisco to our
colleagues- and to all of you
in the audience that represent.
Some of the- in community of
leaders and advocates around
the bay area around the state.
That are clean the moral
question of today just. The
what the state and the
wealthiest country in the
world. House the suffering that
we are seen on our streets with
over a hundred and fifty
thousand. Californians re
night. Who do not have access
to shelter- the double digit
increases were seen in every
major city in recent years- the
fact of the matter is- this is.
A crisis from. The northern.
Hepatitis outbreaks in the
homeless population in San
Diego homeless encampments in
suburban county skip pro in Los
Angeles in California you have
farmworkers sleeping on the
field in our call. One out of
ten Ste. Who are effectively
homeless sleeping in their cars
on a friend's couch taking
showers in the gym and of
course the suffering that we
are seen here in San Francisco
and the bay area within a few
blocks of where we are. As the
of the too many also is a
member. They want to. Our
future thanks for convening
this and let me best. I'm gonna
ask the th question that are on
that's on my mind right now and
if the extent to which various
panels might be able to answer
parts of them- I would
appreciate that for me is the
chair of the housing committee-
really three things we are
focused on. First what are the
specific and crew right
solutions for addressing the
challenges your seats streets
we know there's a diversity
reasons why. Individuals become
homeless and what are the
eight- hue. And sufficient and
effective ways for us to
address the suffering was seen
our streets. Sec this had we.
The very first bill I
introduced this year. A
proposed first time that. Right
than it in. Recent time for
homeless the we establish a
source of for homelessness we
are not going to be able to get
out of this crisis in
202-020-2120 two we need a plan
for the short term the medium
term. And long term. My third
question- for all of you is
assuming we know what the right
answers are assuming. We are
able to find the solutions at
the level that they need to be
funded at. How do we ensure
that we are holding our schools
accountable to achieving these
results were the metrics we use
what are the mechanisms. Used
to ensure everyone involved
from the eight to count and
cities all of the- various
stakeholders. Nonprofit in
advocacy organizations working
on. How do we all hold cells
accountable for ensuring that
we and this is because of what
the vision of this conversation
needs to be. Is a day in
California does not have a
hundred fifty thousand people
every night sleeping on the
streets a day when.
Homelessness no longer exists
and I know we all. Hope that we
can achieve that and that is
why we hear so with that again
appreciate the conversation and
look forward to it. Mister
chair. Thank you very much. We
will start with. Away as well
as departmental service we
have. Lower does moralis from
only if you could please come
up as well as Chen Troyer from.
Department of social services.
And we can start with L. thank
you. Good morning. I'm Lucas
moralis with the legislative
analyst's office I've been
asked by the committee to
provide background on the
state's homelessness-
challenges and provide an
update on major recent state
actions. Seven asked to provide
an update. On. On the state of
homes in California and how the
state has responded in recent
years so I will from this hand
before you know believe there's
extra copies for the audience
as well. If you'll turn to the
first page. This really is a
lot of the comments that may
aid in other opening remarks.
While homelessness is a very
complex problem that has many
causes we see that the high
cost of housing in the state is
a significant contributor if
you look at figure one on the
first page you see that
Californians spend more. Of
their income on housing at
every income quartile and this
is a more income across. As a
comparison to how folks spend
their income across the state
and to the rising cost of
housing. Has exceeded the
increase in wages particularly
for a low income households
that's a lot of stress-
particularly for the one point
five. More than half of their
income towards rent and so for
these populations. A job loss
or an unexpected expense could
result in homelessness. The
turning to the second page. We
see that a mid at these high
cost high cost of housing that
we see in the state of
California has over one hundred
and fifty one thousand people
experiencing homelessness. This
is more people than any other
state of the nation the figure
on page two lays out some of
the characteristics of the
state's unless population. At
some of the when the highlight
who are that the state's almost
by increased by about 16%
between two thousand eighteen
and thousand nineteen. 72% of
the state's homeless population
is on sheltered overall 27% of
the homeless population is
chronically on sheltered. This
information is based on the
twenty nineteen point in time
found. Out while the twenty
twenty point in time count has
taken place those results are
not just yet of it well from
the federal government. If
you'll turn to the third page
of the handout you'll see a
image that depicts how the
homeless population is spread
across the state. As was
mentioned already there's a
great concentration of
hopelessness in the greater LA
region. Overall we see that
about two thirds of the state's
homeless population are spread
with in the seven it continues
of care that are identified in
the map. The remainder so the
one third of the homeless
population reside among the
other thirty seven CEO sees.
It's also likely that these
numbers aren't under account-
we know that efforts to produce
an accurate in concur and
complete count are hindered by
a number of factors. Including
the transitory nature of the
homeless population that makes
them inherently difficult to
count. As well as other
limitations as was mentioned.
Individuals that are couch
surfing or families that live
in overcrowded housing are just
not to mention that our is
difficult are are easy to be
sure in the point in time
county. Represent an important
dimension of the state's home
with. This crisis. So have you
provided the con. For the
breath of homelessness in
California I'll transition to
discussing efforts to address
homelessness turn to page four.
Starting out as a higher more
conceptual level we see that
there's sort of two main
buckets. The first approach are
mechanisms that lasts but may
offer only temporary solutions
the for example things like
shelter that are generally
ease- more cost effective have
lower barriers of entry and get
them up and running more
quickly. The downside to this
is that you're not the read is
that and folks lean back into
homelessness. Then we also see
other strategies that while
they cost more it may have more
long term benefits for example
permanent supportive housing
which was discussed in the
opening comment. To be out more
permanent of the red. You see.
Need more cost and a longer
time to get these types of
services up and running.
Turning to the fifth page of
the handout. Sir to get into
more specifics about what the
state has historically done to
address homelessness. So we see
that California in partnership
with the federal government has
a struggle administered a
number of programs that help
address- the needs of
individuals experiencing
homelessness here we see sort
of the very first type of
programs are those that help
building new. Affordably priced
housing primarily been through
things like tax credits that
provide tax breaks to
developers without another
exchange for that you see them
reserving units for lower
individuals. You also see types
of programs that help
individuals of for housing
these are things like vouchers
that provide payments directly
to landlords and make units
more affordable for.
Individuals and the last
grounds are health and Human
Services. Well these programs
may not a- provide health
benefits the provide other
types of. That build help
develop self sufficiency in
that way might help people
prevent or come out of
homelessness. In the middle of
page fire that there's a number
of state department that had
been involved in administering
these types of service some of
the key ones are- are each deal
at the state and the council
that was established in recent
years. But then you'll see a
number of other departments GFS
as well as cal that have their
their own homelessness
programs. Funding for these
programs come from for a
variety of different mechanisms
and we said we've seen that
over the years the amount of
funding available for these
programs as varied we've seen.
Even more recently that there's
been significant one time
augmentations. What about the-
of way in which the state has
historically been involved if
you'll turn to state. To page
six we talk about the local
level response we've seen that
while the state has provided
funding it's really at the
local level where- services are
provided. Relying in part on
the state and federal sources.
And local governments are most
knowledgeable about the
specific needs of the homeless
populations in their
communities. And making
decisions about what is the
right mix of approaches make
sense for them. As in
recognition of this we've seen
quite a bit of flexibility
given to local governments and
exercising how these programs
are used- we highlighted the
middle the page a few examples.
Of funding sources that either
a state- sources that provide a
lot of flexibility or measures
that local governments have
taken upon themselves to
identify new sources. To
dedicate towards homelessness
response and we- government.
The state thing I. Was in a
housing or rent stabilization
efforts that can bring relief
to the space. So in summary
here that the key is. The local
response has really been driven
by locals own decisions about
the challenges they are facing
and what makes sense to help.
Us homelessness in their own
communities. So what I just
presented has been sort of the
historical nature of the state
and local response. But if
you'll turn to page seven we'll
see that in recent years that
dynamic has become has evolved
and we've seen the state take a
more active role in helping
locals. Support the homeless
needs within their own
communities the chart on page
seven highlights some of the
major state actions in recent
years. The state has generally
taken a year by year approach
in considering and authorizing
new funding sources. Towards
helping address hopelessness.
All these major actions have
authorized over three billion
dollars towards homelessness.
And whether these funds have
been of authorized by the
voters in the place of no place
like. Are on. The legislature
and the governor through the
project budget process. To that
each of these programs has
their own set of parameters
that identify the eligible uses
of the funding. Identify
requirements set methodologies
for allocation and establish
their own oversight mechanisms.
So all of. Them are relatively
new. The first until the end to
which we can to about. What has
been achieved it has some
limitations but over the next
few pages I'll talk about each
of these three interns are the
highlight some of the key
features what we know today
about how the programs are
working. On page eight we turn
to no place like home. Which
was established by the
legislature but then authorized
by voters this part of
proposition two and a twenty
eighteen. This program is
specifically targeted towards
new construction you have been
or rehabilitation of existing
housing. Individuals
experiencing the ana so he see
interest and target specific
type of homeless population. A
lot of this in has already come
out there's more money that
it's expected to be dispersed
over. The next two years- but
we have heard of that at least
the funding that was available
or made available through the
twenty nineteen twenty budget
years estimated to build
between thirteen hundred and
eight hundred additional units
on the seas are permanent
supportive housing units. On
page nine we turn to the
homeless emergency aid program
heap. This was a new program
that was established is part of.
Twenty eighteen twenty nineteen
budget cycle it's administered
under the homelessness
coordinating and finance
council allocated on a one time
basis five hundred million
dollars in grants to local
governments of these are cities
and continuum of care you
provide a quite a bit of
flexibility on how these. Funds
were you. Sort of the bottom of
page. Some of the ways in which
local governments using the
funding. By services to make
capital improvements make a
provide assistance and as well
as help homeless you. What we
see in this program that
homeless youth was one of the
particular out populations of
interest and there is a
requirement that to use these
funds local jurisdictions
designate- emergency shelter
crisis. So then these are ways
in which the programs have been
shaped to provide and support
very specific. Purposes there
is. To page eleven we have the
homelessness housing assistance
and prevention program. This
was just authorizes part of the
nineteen twenty budget cycle
and here again we see sort of
funding from the state going on
a one time basis this time six
hundred and fifty million
dollars towards local
government whereas he paid
funding to cities and going to
care you see this program.
Communities working cult to
address this is within their
communities as a condition of
getting some of these funds.
Seen third less progress a lot
of in his yet to be released-
for all these programs we see
that there's reporting higher
men's that require recipients
provide updates on how it's
going for the heat program the
first annual report was just do
in January and we understand
the administration. Are
reviewing those reports a
better sense of. A how can how
local governments are using the
funds and to what effect. On
page twelve of the out we just
mentioned that. There's been an
expansion of the state's
involvement in the state
portion of the low income
housing tax credit five hundred
million dollars authorized as
part of the nineteen twelve.
It's to the final note make
here that. This edition of the
recent action. To help support
locals it's really been up to
the local level where a lot of
the services are provided and
there's been a lot of
discretion in these local
governments providing sources
in a way that makes sense for
them. And so soared up on the
Avenue on the final page of the
handout on page thirteen we
just highlight some key local
government efforts. To provide
services in their jurisdiction
we see a- making their own
policy discussions we highlight
here Los Angeles county the
stop the final of a flexible
funding pull. That brings
together funding from a variety
of sources to provide rental
assistance and other services
to those individuals that are
experiencing homelessness in
their community. And we see
jurisdictions popping. Their
own ballot measures to
authorize additional funding
toward this is a we see not en
Los Angeles city and county as
well as Senate. In Alameda
county. To give you a flavor of
not for this. The state but the
also the way in which state and
local interacted I'm happy to
take any questions that you.
Great before we take questions
just wanna highlighted for
people who are interested in
actually obtaining the-
legislative analyst's report
you can find on their website
eight. Google legislative
analyst's office for a few
Google the- we are committed
all on our website. But with
that the committee any
questions for illegal. This is
for. I'm just a few quick
questions- in terms of the
undercount at the accuracy of
the numbers Sir Alan's for us
especially. Since we're
providing oversight it and how
do we properly yes the effect.
Are you can example are part
time count twenty nineteen was
hundred individuals who are
homeless though- are a to my
system we that we currently
have where individuals who are
says on the street. But through.
The programs and- provide
services we probably have three
thousand individuals in our
database- so that's- and so
when we do these point counts
and the numbers continue to
increase because of Harper more
volunteers. Whatever the
reasons are. It may be that
there isn't more homeless
stages we didn't count them at
the first time or order were
under counting as you in a bit.
So what is what would you what
are your thoughts on that
should we be. Utilizing other
data sources should we be
continuously counting instead
of relying on the points I'm
can I do know that had requires
that but I like to know your
your perspective on that. So
have a clear. But the-
characteristics answer this and
the do not only number but the
character. There is of the most
popular in any community is
important to understand what
are the right types of services
mix of services to serve the
population effectively. The
point in time counts to provide
a useful estimate- as we as we
mentioned that there are so the
limitations of that to the
extent that other data sources
can be used. To provide
comprehensive picture that'll
just help make more informed.
Is an- decisions allocate to
the we would think you would
agree that some point we
probably should utilize utilize
day says the value at. Working
search image like for example
they to my system I'm- on be
biased here but should we be.
Allow it should we should the
state be collecting that data
aggregating it. Does add a plea
assess whether we- rooms where
of funding are actually
reducing homelessness yeah
we've seen in the keeping have
program that there are-
requirements for responding to
provide internet metrics on how
those funds are being used in
for any state program we would
say that expect oversight is
important to ensure that those
dollars are being used assembly.
And in my- the rams are
utilized in terms of housing-
in terms of like investment in
a mental health services or or
or medical detox or sabes
prevention- are we making the
proper investments and that
should we be. I cal reimburse-
those services. Rose in the
medical community what are your
thoughts on that. So home is a
very complex problem into the
there's no right approach one
of the things that we've talked
about is thinking about. What
response of the state. Event
plate. The state and local
local governments and can be
purchased and are just one way
in which and gather permission
to start making those
decisions. What is the state
role what do those programs
look like are there priority
prop populations that you'd
want to invest some specific
attention to. Us those are some
things you want to. Thank you
very much. That. We also just a
lot of issues that you
mentioned as a matter of fact
and medi cal. In spite deep.
Question answers so that's that
are the part of other such
yours so. The question. Let up
the street from the promise of
services. Good morning Mister
chair and members- I will not
spend time repeating the
information we've already heard
about the emergency with
respect to homelessness I think
it's very apparent to all of
us- so I do we take the
opportunity to talk about the
governor's budget proposals for
this- within that context- I'm
I'm January eighth the
governor. And order that built
upon the prior efforts you were
just hearing about- to set
forth a comprehensive state
response to homelessness the
order expedited the
availability of state assets in
order to help with those
solutions it's stood up a state
this response team. Establish
the new California access to
housing and services fund.
Shortly afterward on January to
the governor released his
budget proposal. The budget
proposes to invite seven
hundred and fifty million
dollars in general fund to that
new finder that I just
mentioned and that's going to
be the main subject of my
comments. But I. Mentioned that
there were six hundred and
ninety five million in total
funds proposed for the medic
how much. Your California all
initiative which will address
some of the- issues that Mr
Fong just raising. Here is for
the state to lead with
resources and technical
assistance but to still
acknowledge as we always have
that local governments and the
partners their- play a critical
role in solutions. At the local
level for all of our
communities. As the minister of
the state safety net programs
and several targeted has been
support and client assistance
programs we believe CDSS as
well positioned to carry out
responsibility for
administering this new access.
Thing and services act and
fund. Our goal is to develop
mechanisms as quickly as we can
so that if and as soon as a
lead teacher approved the
proposal we can get the funds
out the door. We're working
toward this goal
collaboratively with other
state and local nurse some of
whom are here today- and with
advocates and experts and we
really look forward to working
with you on the details
throughout the legislative
process. Hopefully for- early
action by the legislature. So
we need- in addition to the
seven hundred fifty million
dollars in general fund I just
one mentioned I also want to be
clear that the fund is intended
to be able to receive
contributions from federal
local and private sources to
augment the total resources
that will be available. The
resource to be used for our
purposes first AB to develop
additional affordable housing
and work on the supply side.
Second to provide such. Facing
homelessness and tendency
support services along with
that rental sub. And third to
help stabilize boarding care
homes which I think Mister and
you've already reference today-
for individuals who require
that kind of care. All of the
individuals and families Sir by
the program will be homeless or
at imminent risk of
homelessness. And when his
broader approach in recent
years to housing and
homelessness issues the
services and supports will all
be offered a housing first
model. The intent to bring the
housing separate three funds to.
Services so we're improving
long term outcomes in
supporting individuals to not
only get and obtain housing but
to remain how honest.
Structurally the governor's
proposal is for the resources
from the fund to be distributed
to regional administrators.
Experience and established
partnerships locally with that
remark I've described the
regional administrators need to
collaborate locally to
prioritize among the needs of
their regions the work of those
administrators will be subject
to attack on administrative
costs to ensure that the
overall funds are achieving
their intended purpose. We
believe critical to be
innovative in our approaches to
solving the problems of
homelessness and the cost rate
in California. The regional
approach in this the proposal
is intended to incentivize that
collaboration. And to ensure
that we're tackling these
challenges within broader
geographic areas that are
connected to each other in
terms of their need. And that
residents move between. We also
believe a regional approach
will bring a companies a scale
and allow for us to streamline
key processes that we can get
the funding out the door faster.
Some local jurisdictions have
already employed model similar
to some of what is. Included in
the proposal from the governor.
For distributing this funding
and will benefit from what
they've learned as we work to
and acted on a statewide level.
Together our goal is to reduce
St based homelessness and to
increase the stability of
housing for Californians.
Across the state so. Overview I
am also happy to take your
questions. Thank you I thank
both of you for your good press
shins and let me start by
thanking administration for
putting for the proposal that
does have can monies for
another one time investment
this year I will say I'm not. A
super. To I think we the
question whether that a- about
obvious is a question that we
will have during the budget
process- I wanted to. Know a
little bit about who should be
sort of leading the strategy. I
wanted just note in the LA-
report came out a few days ago.
Our while the report plotted
the fact that we are going to
be increasing- a greater state
wrong and the soonest- it
suggested that even with this
plan there still of a lack of a
cohesive approach to
homelessness. At his a bit of a
fright. Approach homelessness
and- I know. Speaking to a lot
of stakeholders around the
state when you have the he
program focused on monies
cities and continues of care
when you have help money's
gonna local governments and-
accountability how does all
this mash and so I'd love to
hear from both of you. Your
thoughts on who should be
leading this effort how do we
how do we create accountability
we have so many different actor
stat we are. To some degree
empowering- but it does feel
pretty fragmented and not a
cohesive. I'm so I think it's
important to recognize that it
takes all of us that all of the
partners at the state level and
the local level bring different
things to the table that are
necessary to confront the
challenge. Internet through the
state. And it's true locally so
we've been working very closely
with our partners who operate
some of those other programs.
In the development of the trip
bill language that we've
proposed. I'm to you and we
also do operate some. Graham's
apartment already- so some of
that fragmentation already
exists- it's also important to
acknowledge that. Also comes
along the medi cal healthier
California for all peace and so
to some extent there's a lot
that's happening in the housing
and I think Human Services
space in order to integrate the
services are so that. Thing and-
being housed I'm a where we
have it but it is the case that
we are all going to need to be
at the table to other locally I
would say the same- are our
vision is that the regional
administrators will be entities
that already have those
partner. Be. If they are not a
local government themselves
then they certainly will need
to have a history of partnering
closely with. Local governments
to so in some ways we are not
necessarily creating something
new so much. As adding another
configuration of how people who
are partnering together now.
Can you to partner. Could you
just elaborate a little bit-
certainly agree with the- the
hope of collaboration but- is
there. Are their power seize
within the trailer bill which
or otherwise to really. Ensure
the collaboration require
accountability again from
perspective are being asked to
give money to different
stakeholders it's just unclear
if. How do we ensure that what
we are hoping to get on
actually gets done yes
appreciate that. I'm up front
there is language in the
trailer bill that provides-
criteria that the regional
administrators need to meet in
order to qualify for the
funding and that includes a
demonstrated history of
partnership- and X. specific
set of experiences in the
housing home the space- so. So
that is one sort of layer of
demonstrated partnership. Also
requirement in the trailer bill
for them to coordinate with
with local partners to identify
what is already happening and
where there may be gaps so that
can be blending and rating
existing funding and efforts-
and so that is where it would
be part of the plan that they
would be bringing back to the
department so we will be.
Reviewing and ensuring that
they assessed. What is already
happening with their partners
with existing funding streams
and that this is helping to
blend braid and bridge the
gaps- we also then will.
Performance based contracts in
those. Ability measures- which
were in the process of to
create right now I'm and those
also will reflect whether or
not they are succeeding in back
collaboration. And advocacy
Elio if you have any comments
on this obvious in your report
you suggest there's a bit of a
lack of medicine fragmentation.
And somehow we address that in
I guess related to this is sort
who should be leading these
efforts I know for example we
created the homeless
coordinating council a couple
years ago. They're supposed to
court they have a small staff
they don't have an executive
director. Even help funds. Just
wondering who should be driving
lesson and what are the first
steps that. Whoever is driving
the should focus on. Recommend
the legislature should to think
through as it develops its own
strategic plan as we recommend
in our report. You know as you
there's there is you know that.
Shin and different up as the
from establish a new MacInnes
of delay serve to look within
the department of services. So
we think that you consider the
right approach you continue to
leverage the existing
mechanisms as a way of
delivering services well you
have time to think through
convene individuals through the
mechanisms like today. A and
then make decisions about what
is the right state role
considering what are your your
goals and priorities and making
sure that you have solution.
With but it is difficult task
and one that we don't have a
ready made solution. Which is
why we think that sort of take
the time to. Make think the
those decisions and- years
sometimes existing mechanism
provide. In the near term leave
to local governments is
important. And in the long term
providing that strategy. For
how to set this. It's making me
productions. Address the
homelessness process. In the
long run. Thank you. Thanks
thank you I think you very much
for the prison so I think it's
law that guy has set up up for
to of this proposal for three
quarters of a billion. My
overriding a can. Is that it's
one time and that the I'm is in
so. Up with the that there's
real no amount that would be
serve. Today however. I think
we need to do deep and find
more a resource. Excuse me. A
and to that are on in nature
and- the other I that I ask you
address is but there's really a
I think you talked a lot bit
about but there's a lack of
specificity in the right now
and I think if I understand a
correct we're out allege. To
appropriate this money now with
the understand figure out later
with space is and that is.
Really not something as the
chairman of her put up in a
member this can that. AJ does
not work me so how would you
propose that we align ourselves
a- providing. The visitor of.
In the but process so we know
we approve the by so in June we
know what we're gonna. And then
I have some specific on how the
governor said the image is so
proposed to al. Thank I'm so
with your to your for point on
on research Hey I certain your
not the only one that I've
heard already at the morning
meant that an I think they the
sort of I'm going. I goal for
the state in it find those on
resources with the Kern economy
and to the I'm sure of what
those resources are gonna be
going for so the per this.
Winter we went to funding but
it does allow for invest and in
addition to the resources they
mention earlier from from so
including per. And I think that
that I. Is that is that it cap.
For that as we- and then it.
Wait how. The some king we have
an on going out to evaluate is
work as we continue to move and
for I do think the problem will
be so. Within the- year or a
couple of the said this is
going to be an on going even
though despite resources are
when time in the and with
respect to the of space. We
really look working with you
and your Ste to try to down.
The particular are you would
like to be clear about it we've
had. Any and- calm some of
those my detail come. To it is
that we- vita what we hope is
in France. I'm a for a program
that were from to and I'd post
for the most could piece but we
certainly well additional input.
You know they are to have a
calm about any just. Brown yes
aren't kids that the for is a
stands today does per a bit of
discrepancy department of
social service and our CASF and
what are we that you know since
about the number of region's
the with government raising the
as the funds are one that sort
of merit you gosh over the
coming extended the pledge.
Thirty is was are things that
can be. Into the old land. And
establish the program. Action
the legislature would want to
go into the to the beyond that
sort of bigger picture. Those
are six similar press that have
been set on of approach the
stay has is to delegate revenue.
At two local got to their home
and serve to this is that there
are certain areas of the law.
You could continue to use this
model that we place today to
delay those things are.
Priorities the you let me into
the specific at least as stand
kind of book that the
administration of. Oppose it
when I first the a proposed I
re that of the purchase of foot
motor. Properties we be. One of
the priorities to at I think
you I it as affordable how per.
And. Eight would like to know
Sir of where the admit is on
the specific right now. So with
for to the of housing
development they is a
difference in the trailer bill
and I was just look for that's
fine although sage. Which is to
the to being of the re use of
for are possible and that made
things some of what you are top
about. So I think there's an op
both with for to property but
all. To men to take in every
using exist. Number for. Our
for. Affordable and I is a said
that continue to be. Arm and
anticipate use. He said ugh
sometimes nexus of stern fifty
thousand dollars in called. Do.
It's extremely important that
we do that but- please to post
now it's not gonna go very far
that's how we allocate it. That
point that there is also a
reference in the trailer bill
to the fact that- uses. And
where we would be establishing
a dollar threshold to ensure
that the funds are not over
Rendon subsumed by only that
use because we want a balance
between the uses that are
proposed. Thank you a not- use
the funds was the for a board
and care- as I think we both
took a disk. It's an important
issue- that needs to be
addressed. Do you have a- CERN.
And that is the board care
crisis- is. One of our- it is
it it's broader than- just
homelessness in of affecting- a
seniors so of the disabled- on
other categories of
individuals- who are not
necessarily. I threatened with
homeless. It's a- this that.
I'm not so sure the so in to
the boarding the cry autumn.
Inside of this particular fund
it probably have its own
discrete funding source. I have
just one on this issue so and
as I've already spoken about it
today- I don't want to diminish
the importance of it and take
away funding from. Up providing
solutions but I think there it
may be back up some separation.
I don't know if you have any
comments on that but it. I
think something we should be
thinking about sure well we
are- department social services
we are also the licensing
entity for our facility which
three. It was a- mental
facilities in a and residential
facility for the elderly- and
that capacity we are licensing
division does work- quite a bit
the licensees who are
experiencing challenges in
keeping their doors open
technical system passed city
already- so some of that work
is happening and we're happy to
collaborate with you. To try to
get what we've I'm not ext. How
to gap and with respect to this
specific uses from the fund the
idea is that. It may be for
example an operating subsidy or
of a rental subsidy- but it is
intended to be targeted to the
facilities that are serving
this population so there is
sort of a larger category of
the burden care facilities. And
there is a subset of them that
specific service population so
that's the focus for the
specific use of the fine but
again happy to work with you on
all fronts. And I think chair
of the larger. It's hard to
mean interrupt you but- therein
lies the problem before only
addressing that subset. Of risk
for. Of a much broader crisis
that needs to be addressed. The
third tab- a bucket of money I
or up to of this money was used.
Since some. I think. Xin aspect
of how is something that we
haven't done enough of- and to
of the more people we keep from
entering homelessness the of
clearly the better off we and
it's a much much more. You very
limited reap in. The at least
in some of the increase the
dramatic increase that we're
seeing in homelessness is
largely due to people who are
newly entering says because
they have. Issue with their
ability to make that law the
rent payment- things of that
nature- so I want. To more
focus on. On that particular
expected. Which for. Answers to
questions. Thank you. For I
just a few questions I but I
certainly want- a day I
appreciate the governor coming
to Bakersfield a few months
back and we only had a
conversation of about a number.
In terms of it I just to piggy
back on. He blames question we
did have a come in about stable
funding is there is there and
discussions and imitation about
looking at a five year plan to
try to as as LA outlined maybe
putting together- a more
coordinated effort and funding
that so that their stability
for the providers- if your-
goal is. See you. Lies yeah.
Aboard if it's to be more-
housing. What housing on online
that can't be done in in one
year is there a conversation to
do that as I mean actually
deferred to- alley who I think
it's gonna be a expand. AB
council believe please being
some did you do planning that
you can prop speak to okay when
she's here you did highlight-
that you were developing simple
space measures- within can can
you. Shed some light on what
was will look like a- Hey is it
still be a teasing that out in
a you know yeah cat let us know
what it is or are you a it was
a more information yeah
absolutely wheelchair it I
don't I'm not prepared here
today to sort of provide the-
lines of what specifically it
is but we have been looking at
the other programs that
already. This the data that's-
as you mentioned in my and also
outside of a time I. S. it.
Came with reporters what is.
Cooley and trying to sort of.
Pull all of that together into
what could be a meaningful way
to measure success. So we will
absolutely share more of that
information so there's a
conversation using HMIS and
other data points the terms of
the term. Before their- which
is. I am we want to rely the
edge of my data Sanders we
don't wanna. The will or we
don't need to but we also
recognize that not everything
that we are going to want and
need to collect information
about a already be captured.
Okay and my last question in
terms of and they certainly.
There are or realities that are
different in terms of urban
homelessness and rule
homelessness it certainly in
the real committees
transportations in is an issue-
more more spread out- at. Is
there recognition within the
governor's proposal of about
the- ensuring that the rule
committees also. Receive
adequate funding this is
certainly I will concede the
point that a said as a- as- a
portion and we've not most of
homelessness is it. Open
centers but- a how do you how
do you how do you. Yeah that
would it would save is that the
trailer bill outlines- factors
for the allocation of the
funding. They in the pick
county of homelessness but they
are doing digital housing needs
assessment. And in the to the
right burden- that individual
are facing a community so it's
it is an attempt to sort of
comprehensively look at the
factors that are leading to the
cost crisis. And to
homelessness across the state
okay and one last question and
in terms of the governor's
proposal to expand Medicaid al-
to include and booze preventive
health care can you expand on a
what it wouldn't. Include the
taxes include a metal services
counseling services abuse Iggy
is out on the table so I'm
afraid I have to defer to
probably three nine year and
within the department of health
care services to talk more
about it I think that that in
broad strokes. The point is to
integrate eight physical.
Health services for individuals
with needs and- cost. Jackie
what that's going to look at I
know they going. Subcommittee
hearing next we and I believe
that's right. Will be there for
that. I hope they will be a to
share more with you about that.
Thank you I also had a- few
questions as well- just wanted
to get into the- issue
regarding why the department
was chosen. To leave this
effort could you describe to me
what efforts on the department
handles in terms of affordable
housing development. But we
don't currently have programs
that that- focused on the
housing development per se what
we have our housing and
homelessness programs that
targets but take populations-
and matching them to have it
and so they- need to work at
the local level we- I'm-
there's and with other
providers of affordable housing
but we- the part. Appropriate
five I'm a we're going to be
partnering with others within
the state who do you have that
experience- and we already have
been in the development trailer
and will be on an ongoing basis.
Notation to specifically the
department the working with. I
know I don't believe that
specified in the in in terms.
Into support services could you
describe the specific program
in the amount of fun and you
given the service right now we
have. A specific amount and
part of the idea of me just
current for our miss I know you
do hello I'm sorry funding for
the works you do other areas if
you can walk to us the amount
of money. I mean ask to join us
it works on our help. Branch to
the- that we- operate probably
even better than I can. More so
in the V. Graham that we
oversee at CDSS we have the cal
works how support program
that's a ninety five million
dollar annual program to rapid
re housing program for homeless
cal work please we also have
the cal works homes assistance.
Sixty million or so are you am.
Our some and assist with sort
providing- hotel there's other
see shelter as well as
assistance with obtaining- of
housing I terms of last month's
rent deposit but center. We
also have the bringing home
program. That's a two five
dollars. Available over three
years that's for homeless child
welfare involve families I we
have the housing a disability
advocacy program that is
targeting sort of the
chronically homeless it's
provides housing supports and
also assist that population
with- getting on to some
benefit programs like SS I it
struck. That's a twenty five
million dollar- annual
appropriation I and then we
also have the home safe program
is for senior years that are
housing and stable and-
involved with the adult
protective services system
that's fifteen million dollars.
Available or three years. All
we are one time it depends the
so pro is on an annual basis as
is the cal works almost
assistance program- bring
families almost three years-
the home state programs three
years- in the housing
disability advocacy program is
annual so it's sort of a court
room. Great armed. So given
that and given that this is.
Only one time funding are how
how would you do. Designs a
program around one time funding
for tennis supporter services
and completed financial
services I'm so is so what we
would be doing is releasing an
RFP to the regional
administrators would apply a we
will grant the funding-
allocated across the region
advance two eight one regional
administrator per region and
will be identifying based. That
I described and the specific
server they think are most
needed locally so an example of
tendency support services might
be legal services- they might
be mediation between the land
more than Ste our housing
navigation service those things
were in. Talk about tennis
service. In regional ministers
not individuals within DSS you
to Xin them as being-
government agencies or correct
the only the only exclusion in
the trailer bill is of the be
private for profit and to. But
the be exit. Local government
you consortiums of local
government entities are could
be non profits. I didn't can
can you walk us through the
twenty for which minister. It
also might my collar was that
we can you just the three.
Mission of the region's yeah we
not yet provided the break down
of the regions that we propose
we- have drafted something
that's working its way through
the administration and that we
will share with you soon- in
order to identify those regions
we- are looking. Governance
structures. I'm in. So I
measures need. And trying
identify the group that feel
the most appropriate based on
all of that and then we will
share that with you- at the
allocations are specifically
broken out as a- and earlier-
in the trailer bill the factors
are laid out so that's the pic.
That's the regional housing
needs assessment- and- ting.
Right burden for fan so I'm
trying and the specific pieces
my trailer bill- about regional
administrators what I mentioned
earlier in broad. Strokes with
the need to have a history all
go out. To have a history of-
understanding how supply. In
the region- they need to have a
demonstrated history of local
partnerships- that position
them well on and we need to be
able to demonstrate why they
can operate across the region.
In is in is there a reason why
this is a- you're pretty
significant archer from the
infrastructure that's already
in place around. Homelessness
the team is of care which is an
existing for deck zero reason
for that departure I'm the
reason the departure is that we
are trying to approach is on a
regional basis and so there is
no entity at this point that
would cut across the regions in
the way that we are looking for
having said that I entirely
possible that a continuum of
care or consortium of them may
be an applicant to be a
regional administrator so how
far we are departing- or not it
depends in part what entities
come forward and are. The con
performance space. In the
previous two years there is a
certain structure around the
funding for homelessness- did
this would stop that funding to
county cities CEO sees and then
start to non funding is there a-
why that is in terms of- that.
That's significant a departure
for the previous two years I'm
again we are attempting to
innovate and to address this at
a regional level- and so the
structure is slightly different
under this proposal and we will
be collecting the data and out
comes to identify how that
works out. I'm we think that it
it is important address it on a
regional level- and we expect
all of those existing partners
and all of the work that they
are doing and have done to be
leveraged in this new
configuration and for them to
be fully at the table and
benefiting. From the infusion
of these additional resources
so I really really want to
emphasize that we don't feel
like we are departing from
lying on we want to build upon.
What is already happening but
was the real issue trying to
address. I'm if people across
regions and the degree to which
all this if you look at. The
chart that lord aside and in
her hand out I think you see
the concentrations they don't
really and each county line to
reach continuum of care pine.
So is it that you're saying
that you're finding that be to.
Says moving from LA to orange
in Orange LA can worker to.
Tulare I guess that's I'm just
understand what probably trying
to solve at at I don't know the
we have is data source to point
for you other than Anneke and
based on what we are finding in
the programs that we operate is
how it works but okay when it
these talk about this. Because
we- if you talk to all of us I
think we'll three housing is
originally is so makes sense
that we have been to approach
the construction of housing as
well as the construction of.
Facilities for the homeless in
a regional matter where which-
told me. Cities and counties
more accountable I'm trying to
just. I I'm I'm not quite
understanding what the regional
homeless issue that you're
strides all for that we're
giving you. Seven hundred fifty
million dollars with no
performance measures with- that
we've seen yet the word and you
know are that we are expecting
to expecting to use performance
based contracts that will have
very specific metrics and we
will absolutely they're more
information. About those in
metrics in you must take a
action without metric without
the region's. Without
specificity on regional
administrators so again what's
the regional you're trying to
solve we will be providing you
with much of the information
that you were just- referencing
before we would have to take
action so the regional break
on. The allegations that we
expect for those is the
performance thanks are all
things that were actively on
it. For you I think. Sweat.
What is the regional this try
to. I seeing a distant I mean
as you I am the how problem and
that is for regional planning
how is a- it was very to the
way that I just that. As a
state need to tack across the
whole state within regions and
within. Is continue there are
many ways that we have. The
jeep V. and we're to innovate
and do it in a slightly
different way but with all
those same partners. At the
table. This game with. Talking
is really around please. With a
talk about in terms a fun you
identified this is an in
regional how thing original
almost approach I still
understand what if game ticker
so within the region so the
regional administrator is going
to be working with all those
local. He'd so not all of thing
is to just at a regional level
going to be year. Then
distributed within the region
so I don't. I'm not sure if
that's making sense to you. But
I'm not. You know but I think
of mental illness yeah sure
this is from. Just a. It is a
model that I guess the you're
you're basing this. Is it's
been done day it is. Some might
not was developed regional
approach. I in no really I mean
part of the mà the my the in
general and what LA has done
with their will have subsidy
was definite top of mind the
nation of many of uses here so
in that the model but speak. To
no any other state has the
scale and scope. One that we do
or the G. size we do in order.
Need to address it and the same
where we the reader are useful
in into one that question the
in. Of how the fund flows nay
it lot of it to the C. season
the counties so in terms and
city's so then with with the
regional manager then
distribute so with this disease
apply to the regional- in. And
that. It is a full. Of flow
that with the money how the
research flow now a this for.
Was a was in place so in the
immediate distribution of funds
would be for the department.
Digital administrators but each
regional administrator would be
planning locally for how they
intended to then use the funds
so they may be going to look.
For missing maybe going to non
profits they- they will go. To
demonstrate to that re. A
straighter that they are able
to. This that are expected
within the plan that that
region straighter with their
partners has identified as
necessary for the region. So
for example the biggest at home
center would no longer apply.
Do you see. What apply to.
Share for this specific of
funds. Thank you. So is. Was
was there re why this. Amount
to see a seems like a fair.
Narrow issue you. Trying to
solve but yet you're asking for
seven hundred and fifty million
dollars to. Work on it. I'm not
sure I know what the narrow
issue is what we're trying to-
deal with is the affordability
crisis and St based
homelessness so what we're-
talking about is affordable
housing developments. Out until
subsidies tendencies. Sir is-
and I think I've heard the
question raised several times
by others as to whether or not
this is enough. Money given
what word. I mean for of that
issue yes but you do. You
didn't ask for money for a of
your a programs in terms of our
other things which are in
existence. You you didn't ask
for money for low income
housing. Tax credits you. Two
gift to give money to a name
region's two unnamed
administrators. For name things
and you would like approval for
that so. Difficult I mean. It's
A. B. the hard to prove dollars
that room well that's a little
easier to. Do that a hundred
and fifty nine dollars I am
your desire recess we aye aye I
hear you. At okay will like
we're gonna have a hearings arm
go forward to a it. More push.
What message of. I think our
chairs serve made the point
Michael me just for my purse
I'm to of white approaches by
the number commerce that I've
with with other ledge. Who will
be part of potentially this
about lack of specific is that
I don't think can underscored a
knife and I think the channel
and allow three jurisdiction
around cal have been a bit with
first by- what went for with
heap and then switch it up for
happened now switch it up for
the third time. So
understanding why we keeps it
up. Understanding where the
accountability is going to be.
Calm I do think the case still
needs to be made a why were
creating another level of
bureaucracy. Of a regional
ministration when we could
simply ask say for example the
mayors who are here- you know
are you using these monies
well. As opposed to again
creating another level of
bureaucracy- the particular for
the legislature we just don't.
Certainly see what was in the
outcomes were looking for our
and obviously we ought even
know what the geographically.
Are so. Lots of questions to be
answered- particularly since
you're asking for early
approval- which I know the LA-
has counseled us not to do. So
you know again from I'm in an
open mind but these are all the
questions that I think you're
going to have to answer for. A
hundred twenty Boston and
obviously the only for
represented here today. Thank
you I would also not which are
meant to burn off with I do
really appreciate the fact
that- even though wasn't
completely fleshed out the
ministration bringing this
forward this proposal forward
and in January rather than in
may- I know oftentimes we could
have seen this in. The end and
having a much more difficult
conversations I really do.
Appreciate that I think what
what we are looking for is just
greater. Understanding for. The
problem the specific issue your
trying to solve we have a
number of existing programs
that we will. Find in to solve
the greater issue that we all
agree is. The issue at hand-
but wanted to get clarity as to
specifically. What is. The
problem. Or trying to solve it
also a if you want to
illuminate where there's been
shortcomings in the current
scheme that's fine as to what
the departure but- critical.
You know. What what. Thickly to
why were. What would you asking
us for. You know. As as to give
you a seven hundred and- fifty
dollar. Check with not a lot of.
Our is. So thank you we are be
going on to our next panel we-
very very happy to. Have number
of may as well as Smith in the
C. of Angeles county of say
just as we as our W. six for
but just to it just I all the-
Hanalei. To come up by mall.
Sense that really appreciate
mayor Liccardo Merrit show for
being here center their time so
if we could maybe have them go
first of questions directed at
them first so that they could
leave with. I would appreciate
that.
The bill the car. And I
also and the bay area's only
representative on the
governor's council of regional
homeless and risers Bob I
wanted to respond to the
specific questions I received
in the time allotment you gave
me which is quite short but I
do hope you asked me some
robust questions because I
would enjoy the opportunity. To
dialogue with you. I'm last
what do I believe are the
causes of homelessness- I would
say first lanes in our mental
health and drug addiction
treatment systems seconds a
shortage of housing. Third
income inequality and fourth
and most importantly because I
think that for example I've not
heard it mentioned yet this
morning unless I missed it-
systemic an institutionalized
racism and I am glad that
Margot c shell is on your
agenda today because she can
articulate it far better than I
can. I also asked how have we
spent our state money are keep
and are happy. And in in a nut
shell two years ago when we-
came to Sacramento to ask for
direct funding cities to
address homelessness. Oakland
had roughly four thousand.
Homeless visuals in our city
and a shelter house city of.
Eight hundred and forty nine
beds. And so while this is one
time money- I will tell you
that I have spent most of my
keep and happy dollars on
expanding my shelter city. So
in year been able to double our
shelter it is just completely
unacceptable allow human beings
to sleep on our streets. In the
wealthiest region in the
wealthiest state in the
wealthiest be in the world. I'm
I want say that we I think
share the state's perspective
that measure of success is not
shelter and I've been a very
outspoken advocate for the
mandate to end homelessness and
in way explaining why I think
it is far superior to a right
to shelter. But the reason that
I have spent my half and keep
monies primarily on expanding
our shop- is because I have
other sources of funding. For
capital. I this is the voters
of Oakland the voters of
Alameda county have passed
their own local bond issues for
affordable housing. I've gone
out and hustle. My
philanthropic community. And if
up with a twelve million
dollars fund to prevent people
from falling into homelessness
eight high hi. Standard of
success for us- Clint what I
have lacked is operational
funds- I do want you to know
that. The vast majority of the
new beds that we have created
an Oakland do come with exit
resources at Ste again our goal
is not just to shelter people
it is to move them from
homeless to house. We have used
our heat and hot monies to
create safe RV parking up for
it the 45% of our on shelter
copulation that resides in RV's
or cars can I and number again
forty five percent. Of our on
sheltered population is in cars
an Arby's. Are we have used it
to create three hundred twenty
two beds in our innovative.
Community mock. I'm a model
that costs. Sir Jeff the cut
brought costs refer half of the
Butte. Navigate in Oakland we
don't have the same money that
San Francisco has we have to be
creative. Two hundred twenty
three beds in our innovative
cabin communities that not only
allow people to go to bed at
night behind a locked door with
their partners their pets and
their possessions. But
something that tradition. Does
not offer and that is privacy.
That is why we have had high
demand and high acceptance
rates for this form of shelter
far higher interest. Than
willing. To our more
traditional congregate shelters.
We're happy for the same rates
up on. Exits. To traditional so
although as high as a rap
housing so. Burke what is and-
shelter leader the winter to a
year round shelter- as well as
to add new Bextor uses shelter
and we are going to in one
month the opening. Families so
we have your money. Twenty and
wrap it this up again I to
emphasize the real we have
spent your money on all the
very thing that the new per.
And this his because we've a to
find other so. For those things
not because we don't value them
and that's another reason that
we encourage you to preserve
some local flexibility- impact
you know again we share the
values that are behind the
governor's proposal for the
seven hundred and fifty million
dollar fund but we would argue
right now shelter is not an
allowable use of the new fund.
I and we would argue he like
ours is meeting the service
rate house. Ste in permanent
part of housing in a- from
homeless to how in prevent
homelessness. We should be
allowed to at least maintain
the systems that we have put up
with your past funds of an
adult not allow those to fall
apart and I think the
governor's office would agree
you've also asked whether these
funds have inspired
collaboration. And I would say
that it has inspired some city
to city collaboration- some of
our interventions in Oakland
have been in partnership with
the cities of Berkeley and of
Emeryville. In some limited.
With the county but I have to
be honest not as much as I
would have hoped- I do again
agree with the governor's. And
US secretary galleys. I believe
that we need more regional
collaboration and coordination-
but I regret to say I do not
believe the creation of a
regional administrator would
accomplish that at least not in
the way it's currently proposed
on the time line that is in
front of us and with the use of
one time funds. Were to about a
permanent ongoing source of
funding that would be an
entirely different com station
but because that is not
currently on the table I do not
think it is worth the trip and
it will be very. To all
difference raiders if you're
talking about only one time on.
As far as the next step but I
would like to see. Yes to come
men. Of honor and secretary
galley for continual. Pushing
that our measure of success is
not shelter it is moving people
from homeless to house and it
is preventing people from ever
experiencing the trauma
homelessness to begin with or
even of housing in security so.
Many in the area in part parks
and sing. I'm aye no one has
raised the R. word today and
that is redevelopment- when I
talk about you know these
valiant efforts at the local
level of locally approved.
Bonds for. Hey in comparison to
the redeveloped. From us. I
also want to give a passionate
support for a legal mandate to
and homelessness- I know that
we are continuing to clarify
what that means I want to say
in response to- mayor breeds
bands we are not intending to
give city or county. On man
it's out new things this and
that I know that I will be part
of a happy chorus that says one
time funding homelessness will
not work we need an ongoing
permanent source if we are
really serious about ending
this travesty so those are my
comments I am very happy to
take your questions. But we'll
go with the car they will have
quite from both. From great
partners in this at.
Homelessness in our region how
to work with mayor Libby Schaaf
Maryland in. All up to grateful
work of your committee. And
what is really emerged. I just
and from the governor of the
lack of years where we can now
one in three point one billion
dollars in. Funding to tackle
homelessness through programs
like at a place like home and
he perhaps course. I really do
want to emphasize I think
governor Newsome for his
leadership in making historic
in. About homeless lap. Postal
this year and if approach in
working with critically with
the mayors the thirty largest
cities. Although that coalition
this year I will not be
speaking on behalf of that cold
will be speaking together and
Sacramento just weeks I'm
guessing you'll hear from us
then I just like to confinement
marks to my own perspectives
and first what you consider the
city of San Jose a very active
in when partner- in this battle
we all face- prior the state's
elimination of redevelopment
agencies we spent forty million
dollars a year to be more
affordable housing than the
other city over that. Time we-
all the way the California's
Court enable us to enact.
Inclusionary housing eight and
to protect that the right of
others. To do the same. I would
provide a laboratory first
state pilot projects including
the leasing Caltrans land. For
action decisional house for the
homeless including rapid bill
tiny home communities. And
since twenty seventeen we've of
fortune every strong
relationship with our county-
to leverage in dollar county
bond. On with. The millions of
dollars a city for bloom
dollars to complete to support
of housing developments- along
with. Since more units are
under construction or in the
pipeline and seventeen other
projects- and- a week. Voters
will keep a measure to. Seventy
million dollars annually to
combat homelessness and build
affordable housing. I am world
posing this year. And it's free
on all commercial about. Of
course none of this is nearly
enough any our community since
not even close out while we're
building the permanent
supportive housing and yes will
need much much more of it. More
flexible funding. From diesel.
For folks still out on the
street. And prior to the city's
receipt of hip funds the city
dedicated fifteen point six
million dollars a year to
homelessness response programs
and he by basically came at a
critical moment and we're able
to. Leverage this eleven
million dollars in such kind
would happen to nearly twenty
four million dollars this year
and where we dedicating those
dollars well three general
buckets first most the funding
is dedicated to getting
homeless individuals. St
archers rental subsidies use of
converted motels creative
diversion strategies- youth and
adult navigation centers and
bridge housing- we've just
completed one of those tiny
home communities is being
leased up in the second
committees up construction
second we've invested in rooms
you that will reduce human
misery and improve safety of
homeless residents everything
from say parking to overnight
warming's shelters to mobile
showers and bathrooms- but
finally most importantly
notices. In the mail shops do
we're investing. And over the
last two cycles- we will have
invested seven million dollars
combined in prevention and we
got to prevention because the
whole. Two three years Asian
with the county. One seven
thousand. We are still staying
are homeless and right. It
became apparent that passes
we're housing people more
people are getting pushed out
onto the street and so we try
to pilot prevention and we
leverage a lot private sector
money back almost fifteen
million dollars. The first- for
our commitment in the counties
also. In for. And what we learn
is this is very active for
spending about. Forty three
hundred. Family and what we're
finding in the flexible a-
since. Ninety then one AT so
for that would help. Are still
housed six months later. A and
so it is preventing
homelessness it's also very
nimble because more than three
quarters those families are
getting assistance within
seventy two hours. Up so
there's certainly an important
debate about the state's next
steps I really appreciate your
willingness to have this
discussion now and I know will
continue but not surprisingly I
join my colleague and- feeling
quite strongly that we- as many
needs behind. This is basis and
we need to treat it like one
and I agree Sir. With my
colleague from Los Angeles as
well we need I'm going in del.
Crisis also not surprisingly I
believe that those dollars
should be directed large cities
seize. S. cities or I'm sorry
in the were the salute are.
Permanent how or housing. Then.
It is critically in. In local
government as well I that one
complaints come in about
homelessness and what's going
on in communities. They won't
go to the John traders. Sure
San Francisco. The cast member
has a leave that one alone. It
is a will take on our account
but he- just late into the
public you know I encourage you
to impose very clear metrics-
there are results oriented
around performance we all have
HMIS data bases we should be
using them and we should be
using them to but scannable.
Performance and so- a finally I
would urge if that was the goal
here is to avoid the cost us a
passing through a lot of
agencies get that nice or the
governor reduce. Expense and I
think cities would happily take
on the same percent a cap on
the mystery of expand.
Collectively for all citizen on
Providence were administering
this program is really critical
given the allocation of he
perhaps that's already out
there we've got programs in the
city centers A. recall another
fourteen million dollars
annually just to maintain those.
The rug out will not. The
alignment and we need to for.
We stand to do more with you
and look forward to working
with you to do more. Thank is
come back to my colleagues for
questions. Mr Shipp. Let me
first start by the two mayors
along with mayor breed- I can't.
A who are who are. Fighting at
the forefront of a job this
crisis appreciate. Striving
mightily- and also appreciate
just how under resource to our-
a couple quick points first of
all with regard to
redevelopment I think you know.
Two point oh bill so Jim bell
had- carried version of it. Our
governor- had step we
understand his perspective
that- that relying on the
general fund for that was not a
path he was what to do- and so
to some degree were a bit stuck
in this conversation- very much
appreciate- that you support
the idea of a permanent source
of funding for homelessness and
specifically- your support
also. Our proposal to reform
the mortgage interest
deduction. Which will. To about
a half a billion dollars when
we know the need is much larger
than that will take it though.
The work with you on that.
Questions have you done a needs
assessment in your respective
cities up. How much would it
cost Oakland or San Jose. To
and homelessness and I. Senate
because I think it's a state
really assistance and I think
if we don't start with the end
in mind. What what it costs to
an homelessness how much will.
Be it's hard for us to have the
early come Xin of how how. How
large should we consider
investing. I've heard
statistics anyway for example.
To house every homeless person
in the state and provides part
of housing might cost to say
twenty five billion dollars.
That's just a back of the
envelope commerce calculation
someone is provided curious
from your standpoint whether.
You run those numbers for your
cities. Note that I'm not
looking at my notes I know
this. By heart- our plan our
path plan that we have
conducted a very deep analysis
using systems modeling on our
existing homeless population.
We estimate that the city of
Oakland need annually on an
ongoing basis a hundred and
twenty three million dollars in
operating funds. And then a
capital experts. Roughly every
five you of about two hundred
and twenty million dollars.
What we are spending right now-
and I can't I can't pull out
the state capitol number for
you but I can tell you
operationally worst being
thirty two million dollars a
year. And roughly half of that
is time money. That spending on
operation and I am I am very
fiscally responsible and very
proud that Oakland just got its
highest rating in its history
last week. I is it that you're
response financially I think it
is. Necessary moral. But we've
got to fix that we are doing
this right now because we
believe that we as a society
going. Eight a permanent
ongoing funding source to end
homelessness I believe that the
political will is there I
believe that the public will is
there I believe we will do that
and so we are. Using one time
funds right now for on going
expenses. Because of that faith
that we have. Thank you. May
have is met- responses after
that the hearing with regard to
specific numbers that tell you
Michael is that we don't need a
permit on going. To combat
homelessness I would make the
capital investments we need I
that will actually get people
housed. It seems to me that
given the numbers that we know
are out there you know we were
able to house. And seven
thousand nine hundred homeless
issues over a period of low
more than three years. With
relatively scarce resources- we
think we can clearly magnified
impact. With a significant
basement now from the state. We
are asking our residents for
more- we're all asking our our
taxpayers to pay more to combat
this were willing to be
partners. Second question we're
here very consistently from-
localities around the state
about the need for flexibility
right local flexibility- and
there's a tension between sort
of local flexibility and
accountability when that the
monies that we're going to
invest actually get back to us
could you tell us how should we.
Please and counties accountable
for the good use of. You do not
want us for were not able to
really prescribe for good
reason how you how we think you
ought to use the funds- jump in
on this one I you know I think-
critical that. The metric in
the accountability. Based on.
But are we getting people how
service staying house and how
many homeless are still out on
the street. It seems to me that
is the measure that is most
important to our communities
and I know that's what's most
important to the state I know
there are a lot of ideas about
how money can be better. Be
used better or worse in any
given community. But I think so
now. I within RCA cities their
different needs depending on.
Rail but yes we have in each
community for example the
centers A. S. had. The opiate a
crisis that I think we seem to
make their cities but we are
today that is. A grappling with
a serious addiction issue and
has been the case for many
years- that does Chris
different set of needs in terms
of but treatment. As well as
intervention. I think it's
important how that such. Now I
just have very strict standards
about the comms. But I gave it.
To hold us accountable comes up.
I would add to that. Because I
don't have the will. Twenty
three million dollars a year
our what we are committed to
doing is. With the limited
money we have always be having
ratio always best. Ensure
shelter in here. So you know
making sure people are doing
all those things and be aware
are still elected officials
that find it acceptable to in
public say that their solution
to homelessness is shipping
their homeless to other. Have
about holding us accountable.
To arms is you cannot have as a
pure outcome at there is less.
Homelessness because you don't
want to incentivize. We see
that that is real and you you
have to protect against. One
five. I know if you were on the
for region home adviser and-
number had proposed this idea
constitutional amendment of
some sort that would hold both
city desire and so the attack.
Want to ask you back to. Read
in her purse. Weeks so I think
it's fair to say that the
proposal that is currently
published is pretty big I in so
our work right now is to put
some some specificity and-
employee in up come. To what
this mandate is because of
mayor breeds of you what at
that she stated today is one
that is not intended and I do
not leave will become part
legal mandate to and
homelessness it is not what is
not intention certainly as a
matter. Does not intention
quite is to spend money that.
Cree clarity about who's a- for
what right now there is no
clarity there are no legal
responsibilities with regard to
homelessness on any level of.
Second it is to again create
here a clear set of results
that are required and
definitions what success looks
like. We also Sir- looking
clear that this mandate include
parents as well. For
jurisdictions that we want to
be kind of certified as- back
to scene the best practices in
reducing homelessness so those
are some pieces of the puzzle
that we are working in
partnership with governor's
office right now and again now
is a good time for peace. What
they- want so that we- there
will be. Armed with a and
potentially at the ballot box
in November. And I am yeah I
really applaud the work-
Schaffner side breaking the
rest the committee wrote push.
Port and provocative idea. I
think can be workable a lot of
work. Idea over the goal line
one thing I would suggest is
that- if we're gonna hold
cities account for outcomes and
we probably want to avoid. What
we know could be a lot of
excitation fixation slit
litigation if this one check
criticized harbor for the
cities and does UC's. That. If
there is a safe harbor that
seems to me we what a lot of
the fear of litigation as well
as the obviously the cost of
litigation itself. Hi this and
just to clarify the proposal is
only a public right of action.
Not private right of action
public. And so only a
governmental entity and I think
the postal before and an in.
General homelessness for the
state. Of Calipari's. There
will not be monetary damages
available but more injunctive
relief as far as who gets the
axe to spend the existing funds
how was funds are spent I am
particularly quickly and
effectively. Thank you again
appreciate your comments- on
this last topic I've been
having many conversations with.
Many DO not just on this panel
but also throughout the state
on how we- if ensure that we
hopefully create a permits are
so funny at the same time I'm
all of us at level city county
level attention regional level-
and do it in a way that's going
to move us forward so looking
for to that work and- thank you
for being here. Thank you both
very much for here I and I can
see your- it looks. Quick
comment and you're welcome to
of I some I'm and of. When we.
I talked de issue of
accountability one of things we
need to stop. We are addressing.
Change is the take place on the
ground because this is an issue
that has morphed over time.
Thank back back when I was the
mayor local government up
dressing home assistance Sam
the issue has. Since that time
was for the- alrp which is can
to of our how of crisis and we
failed in many ways leave to
keep. Up with those changes and
so one of the- metric that. I
think we ought to be judging
ourselves on it is how we keep
up with chair. That's because-
he you make funding system
thing on the ground changes you
need to be able to address
those changes and right now I
think that is addressing the
needs of people who are at risk
for homelessness absolutely ugh
stop. This because- on the
street so I want to get that
out thank you very much for
here and year time is limited
if I can come to that I think
you raise a really important
point and there are some kind
of proposals floating.
Descriptive that would have you
know this percent to five the
first. Housing to funding for
capital and- really. Avoid
walking some down the rigidly
for ever we need to have a
system where people are
constantly evaluating what our
jobs we housing housing cost
balance because we know in the
bay area that we've been adding
jobs to this region and not
produced. The same work. Kate
and I wish that the def con
three warning would have gone
off a little sooner- it is now
all we- sell. With purely
economically driven
homelessness. Which I think is
a new nominee always present
I'm seeing Chen is kind of our-
not in his his head. I really
want to their score that. We do
have a fifty years ago we
didn't have a method like we do
it today the- easily
availability easy availability
cheap availability of. Yeah I
agree in yes several aye aye.
The way you pop. Allow CSE to
be flattered of an- we're
seeing a lot creative ideas
rising out of every. Hi there
is serious about this problem
and we don't yet have the
server but we know that this is
going a. Lot of difference and-
allow. A first let me say thank
you for being. My mayor of a
caring of a bigger schools as a
low I textures might actually
be intensifying. Did you play
you for your leadership. Your
cities you mention. Jeff your-
but the house of love on this
is the quickest thing is mental
health and drug. Maybe I. Maybe
for out a bit more and of how
do you what do you see. Lucia
certainly Ian into it is. We
have been very we will in the
add to it to help was but they
that we find out of capacity
and the goal obviously to deal
with because what what is what
what are your so I guess. From
deal with that well I will
start with the out. Health and
drug addiction is just. The per
of the county government not
the C. of. And will say
Francisco it both so they can
talk kind of both I just want
to have that copy out what I
can say it we know housing
first were. You cannot affect.
Someone's I'm men and they are
state how housing is health and
so to the extent that we
believe that these types of
kind of medical dollars should
all in. Seen as a- this but
with the fat government. Yeah I
would just that I think you
know the complexity of homeless
so I think that we're all well
of it is very difficult to
separate the fact and your- I
bridge. Spec I'd probably be
drug everyday to and- it's hard
to know whether the costs of
the every because we know
there's a lot of positives job
loss there's- medical. She's a
host reasons why people break
up. But it. Three to some of
our studies are is it's going
to take much core at I can say
it is cost it's certain an
affected were saying. And at
you know our speech myself in
help. Me shop may not agree
with me on this one we do not
host thanks but- I do believe.
We need. Forced the way that us
to be compassionate with drug
users or on the street living
in cabinets living in a and
rivers and by that I mean.
There's no way I'm going to get
someone with a methamphetamine
addiction to voluntary they say
it's time for treatment get off
the street ago when. Sample in
Honolulu an operation hope it
having a judge who can order.
Someone who's been arrested for
possession not too long since.
Order them to treat and know
that there is a potential a
jailer two days in jail as a
consequence if they don't go. I
and then and then testing them
for. The point is not to
criminalize abuse not.
Listeners I'm not a note. To in
and with the Camanche system
twenty us to get on the
treatment. And right now we're
not seeing any Bob. Willingness
to do to make that happen now
the methamphetamine yes is
service public safety but to
the- using as well as the
surrounding. The for prosecutor.
Hi city now to look at the-
these blood of folks simply.
Have no serious violent priors
committing violent crimes
because of long term Matheus
window eyes and psychosis. So I
think we have treat the- play
now to get along sentences not
go back to the war on drugs but
rather to have a judge who has
the authority to be able to
tell somebody you got a-
problem you got to go to
treatment. Thank you and I
guess. I've let me for say that
that that. When welcome
addition. Good addiction.
Certainly a lot of Los or Joe
I've I've so talk to the met
them the my community and end
up developing you know but you
know certainly illness. When
they're on the street so I
needs the cause and effect is
of course a very complicated
situation will say that.
Homeless end up in a zero. Yes
citizens are paying for. I is a
very the most expense promises
services addiction services
would you be open to the idea
mental health or G. top or-
perceptions of. A is double
under Medicare. Some the look.
In in in terms of like for
example in the in the there is
I've asked the governor to ask
for- Brian de vote fry and did
to- provide flexibility and-
that that you entered. Well no
it's the it's the eleventh ever
how indeed to give the same of
in covering service under it's
just a mental. Housing Hey.
I'll give all these aye it
maybe the and that too in a
week. I could that. Should an
be spent to stably people that
are fighting drug addiction and
mental health because we know
that that is the most effective
conditions for successful
treatment. I believe the cost
of housing could and should be
covered through Medicaid
reimbursements. Yeah I agree
and I also apply the
governor's- initiative on that
and thank you very much. Great
thank you thank you thank you
both for. Being here today- it
really appreciate the
presentation you made. Could
you talk about. How how quickly
you spent that first round of
funding from heap- I mean just
rob just just a rough terms I
don't need to specific day but
just. To get a sense of- on
that the center for see I think
that you both both had I really
appreciate what I know them but
we work on together. We work to
make sure that we discussion
that the parents are ready to
once they got money they were.
Ready to deploy that money. Yes
in a German. Well you be
passage you get to be better
make sure you using it. We've I
can tell you I know the
deadline is I think a major
twenty twenty one will can be
well of in front of that I
suspect. We're action on the
second time young community
that were usually the sponsors
that construction on that money
is used. And we were told that
we there is application in the
very first day that you're
accepting the heap application-
because we're anxious to start
spending and we are prepared we
had again raise private funds.
To pop it the commute the model
impact think I don't know. Part
what hello. As actually are
helped fund the pilots of our
cabin community model. So that
we were. So yeah your cabin can
have much lower- positive exit
rates are longer standing ones
have very high- exit rates you
know well over 60% the average
all of that get about 55% right
now positive exits in housing
from the little cabins- but we
were. We had already started
front in some of the money
waiting for our checks from the
state to come out we are very.
Are very impatient people. I
just know that. I should also.
Any trouble up some these
programs money aside for
operating for a couple years-
so. The committees recess I two
years that money obviously will
get used until the Dodgers got
and I. Mers are patient co. So
sounds like he with the help
dollars and are gonna be
purpose to soon. Sounds like
you already have planned for
the for that money as well yes.
We've already so our applet as
a big city. In now is in. In in
the new shelter capacity that
we've added one to sustain it.
To improve the flow to a- bàn
three how the floor. I can. All
use of second galley and the
guy. It and then maintaining
their much higher level of
ability to get people off the
streets and in this and see.
But also to move them along to
pay minute. Housing we also are
used it for the for time so
address I haven't Reyes enough
I which is the incomes. Of the
homelessness problem so this
will be the first time that
we're making. A major
investment very targeted
workforce program to actually.
Seen the incomes. The
employability. Police St.
Visual yeah I know I'm- and a
council Tuesday approved were
ready to go fired up. Great
thank you it incense the
governor's current also really
has a focus on regional
collaboration I know shop you
may. This sure a little bit
more about that now the car few
examples which is all
understanding you know our are
there other gaps from the
region we know there gaps in
terms housing production
because we were that's as two
of the three big cities here
seems like everybody's fine
telling Sanders. Francisco to
build but when you ask each
other vigils he's the bill they
don't quite. You could. Not
talk about some of the reason
issue you know we to school
collaborations and again it
kind of takes that you know
block by block knowledge that.
Arguably only me. So for
example our cabin community. Is
actually bringing. This. Can't
men and is meant the strategy
as well and there was a huge
encampment that was right Board
clinic. Although mostly
Emeryville side but we have.
Cal that was ME gave us a part
that the county actually
divvied up there keep funds to
the different cities- after
deducting Oakland's direct
allocation then they divided it
by the- but- the county to
stand up to cabin communities
and a safe RV park that most
people from the Emeryville side
of the line that was right on
our our border we also knew
that they had a building that
was formally being used as a
temporary- and formally. But on
Mr their part. There leasing a
stop building for. At no cost
that's a were funded only. It
it it memory fell out and then
find out in the governor was
giving these FEMA trailers-
just it feels like a few weeks
ago the state or to. County to
read I county in able to draw
the. So that they provide.
Provide that are actually.
Helping the P. that will living
those trailers so we provided
the land we provided that
little caught to ready the
sites to actually be able to
accept the trailers a big part
of the services that come from
the county again with the.
State so that was a great
example of true. That is
sustainable thank. Hi yep you
know back in twelve. Fifteen a
nonprofit organization nay
Modesto how. Are there by
tripping over each other need
the cash Allen offices within
their own. What is result in a
real. Genuine partnership
between seeing county yeah this
is. That's not all the cities
but the city cal. Show will.
Prevention county it is worth
invest in will has kicked in
for me and oversee results
today. We do released a hundred
million no Sir fight L. ability
or this year we're gonna
release I'm sorry I was last
year to release another one
this year. I in in all those
extremely low income projects
the counties making commits
provide support services- wraps
so in lockstep obviously their
disagreements in this healthy
to. These are. But know I don't
as we should prop county. I
don't doubt that there is a re
to this challenge but as we go
through the encampments in San
Jose and we are very diligent
during our vice but Datin HMIS
to it determine where folks are
coming from more. It candidate
will house some in our can so
there are. They're part of our
community recognize it we gotta
get. Great thank so sounds like
a again. Your special. Shops
example- you you look at
specific examples where they're
made a whole lot since. Push it
that I'm any final comments
okay great thank you mashup
melakarta really appreciate you
both being here- we were going
to call. That's two panelists
to take the to mayor spots so
that joint and- is for. Each of
the panelists to stick to about
the- it frame as I think as you
can see your your plenty of
time to be able to cover all
your points especially I ask
questions of we appreciate
everybody's- assistance and- to
that. Can to that time for. So.
Let's with miss Barclay from
the city of Los Angeles. 20%
may I monies might embassy
homes corner at the city of Los
Angeles in the office of the
city administrative officer on
behalf mayor Eric Garcetti
thank you for the opportunity
to be here today to speak about
the critical need continued
state homeless funding to major
California cities. And also
thank you for the hap grants
they really have truly been
flying to the city of Los
Angeles and the other cities
that you've heard speak today-
as refer to by LA- I'm just as
a reminder that the point in
time count for the cat plus
Angeles this our- thousand nine
hundred and thirty six-
homeless individuals 60% of
those or thirty six thousand
one hundred and sixty five in
the city of LA. Twenty seven
dot pattern twenty one or 75%
of the city's homeless
population is not shall. The
city during six in the nay for
cost per. With 569% of renters
more than 30% of their income
on rent. This lack of housing
inventory and thus the lack of
affordable affordability is
creating that flow.
Homelessness in the city. And
why we size sixteen per crease
in our home was county this
year. I noted that he even
haven't been a lifeline to the
city of LA but I do want to
stress that and very. To what
you heard. Awhile from the
makers on the panel as well I'm
that prior to hear and half the
city had been spending thirty
nine million dollars of general
fund initiate the amber.
Program which provides a room
housing and temporary emergency.
Ramps and- annually o'donnell
fund for the Los Angeles
homeless services authority to
provide a sense property saying
winner shelter our age and
administer the court need entry
system which is based on a to
my **** I'm and like other
cities unlike other cities and
such. Anderson city about. So
how a robot affordable housing
finance system for. Thousand
units per year three hundred of
which are supportive housing
units. On the seeks secured an
additional local financing
source in November of twenty in
with proposition eight JH which
will allow the city to issue up
to one point two and dollars
and- finance. Facilities for
some of hopping we anticipate
the funds find up to ten
thousand units- we committed
98% of these funds to date in
the first three years
leveraging each proposition HHH
dollar with an additional two
dollars and investment I'm and
get to the question of
partnership the city and the
county in the housing of the of
the city of. LA I have an- in a
ship to enter all the can of.
Programs are able are available
we have a memorandum of
understanding with the county
has committed to provide
support our to find supportive
services and every unit that
city from that the city for.
And how close committed six
thousand project based vouchers
to support operating subsidies
for those units. Can we
anticipated gap service an
operating funding for these
units but we are currently
working to develop- finance
options to close this gap.
Unfortunately even if the city
had adequate resources.
Construction doesn't happen
overnight and he been have
really been. Meeting a critical
gap that the city can't can't
afford very also similar to the
mayor's you heard earlier.
Today. One of the first cities
to apply for heap finding an
and we've immediately put
eighty five million dollars are
eighty five million dollar
allocation to work to finance
the a bridge home program
creating fourteen hundred and
fifty and housing. Was Sir
because- I'm- we're also
finding right rental assistance
rapidly housing critical
hygiene outreach services. And
as of January first twenty
twenty we committed 99% of our
keep grant while I am fire
about a 50% statement. That
time. We also have plan fifty
point million of our students
seventeen point five million
have grant- we've been there
reserved for eight hundred and
ninety two more interim bad in.
Reyes home possibilities for
all twenty three hundred and
forty two beds at. Impair on
some past grant be as well as
with focus on. Diversion
assistance pending and pending
additional mayor and council
action we anticipate that just
like keep even though have has
a longer spending sense that we
anticipate will. Find it. We
take our first. For these grant
funds play and established a
transparent process and
procedures the safety. Of the
funds- meet these things
actually the approval process
goes through an additional
oversight median decision to
mayor and council approval for
that approval of the spending
of all of these funds for heat
and happy. They've allowed
these funds of all are the city
to build on existing
partnerships. With the county
Los. The county and the city
and the county or joint. It
Berman temp embrace. To find
the operation of those with the
can to fit dollars per bed
print. For sixty six hundred of
the bridge home bands and also
financing the construction of
an additional site in
partnership with the VA- in
your district Mister bloom- for
this snow is on going. Team I
and in please provide services.
And half dollars exhaust and
the three six hundred back has
expired in twenty one in two
thousand twenty one and twenty
two the annual cost great all
the a bridge home beds is forty
one point seven million. The
loss of the funding together
with the guy in our minutes of
housing five. Start
significantly or the city's to
our homeless crisis for these
reasons we urge your support.
To maintain says four models of
heat and how to govern a new
statewide find by distributing
funds to cities and counties
are continuum's of care.
Increase find for the
governor's post. The in dollars
create from the general fund
distribute fining according to
a needs based formula with no
cap on anyone's these
allocation and to establish
allocation similar to hot 40%
to the bill the mayor's fifty
five. Percent to nonprofit
housing developers outside big
cities again on behalf of the
marijuana thank you for the
opportunity speak to you today.
And I look forward to
addressing your question thank
you for your support great
thank you Mister Ramirez my
county valley sure I'll be I'll
be quick here. Thank you
members and- the committee. To
the for LA county. Some
information on our efforts to
combat homelessness. I just
want to maybe give quickly a
background on our can on what
the county has been doing. Is
in two thousand fifteen the
county that have occurred a
plan to tackle. Our board of
supervisors- had a more they
have a moral obligation and
later in two thousand fifteen-
initiate the hopes initiative
in the county of Los Angeles
and this initiative was
basically directive to the city
Cubans is to develop. I'm not a
deal with this crisis. So after
six months public process with
stakeholders in the community-
forty seven strategies were
approved by the board and in.
February of two thousand
sixteen. I'm along with that
came one hundred million dollar
one time Smith. Argumentation
no. Which was I think pretty
bold. Cord to March I'm so. But
LA que voted themselves a
quarter cent sales tax and
which would generate about
three fifty four million
dollars a year for two. We
spent specifically on-
combating to preventing
homelessness. Along with this
after the measure passed we had
a goal of- assisting. Forty
five thousand families and
individuals- to move from
listeners to permanent housing
as well as an apple thirty
thousand additional. Is in in
the void coming home. Then for
in a- in the house with. With
the measure H. funds and over
forty thousand people have
entered in from housing funded
it earned hold a measure age
but that's not enough- mention
here their economic thirty some.
Points of. As the member bloom
and- every day two thousand
eighteen how three people
escape homelessness but a
hundred fifty people became
homeless per day. In regards to
gaps looking outside the home
services delivery system- the
most important that we speak is
the need to overcome resistance
citing. Building you have in
shelters and again as other
people have mentioned we need
an ongoing state fund
commitment that will allow
local regions to build on want
it is. Even happy as you know
we're in a two billion dollar
ongoing state commitment as
recommended by the governor's
council on regional- homes
advisors. You know of the sixty
four million- dollars are grant
it we're getting from from
happen- we can receive directly
any heat money- but for the
help money- thirty million
native thirty eight million of
that will- will be used to
provide service for families
and individuals- in in permits
for. Housing as well as
seventeen of the of those fund
on the term thing and eight
million a rapper housing there
Sir. For a home transition age
use find a like to mention that
over the last few years the
county has participated in and
really. A ripple collaborative
model- in part because the
measure rates in the ongoing
revenue. Which includes. A lot
of cities we have eighty eight
cities in LA county with you
know LA city being the biggest
one- dozens of county
departments we work with a
multiple. Authorities as well
their seventeen I believe in
the county of Los Angeles-
doesn't law enforcement
agencies and many many
nonprofits and faith based or
Bates faith based
organizations- the county I
truly believe that the half
funding will strengthen the
regional collection has been
building. Since the adoption
adoption of the county homes a
strategy in two thousand seven
actually the same day that the
city adopt there's a G. we
work. In tandem on the
strategies and jurisdiction's
voter for the energies the same
day- I think that really it.
Should no funds. For again.
Continued ongoing for thank you
great thank you we'll go to
deputy secretary. Sudden thank
you for I am so I am not to get
to and without lot of this is
already been covered in we did
pull together a bit of the
behind all of you and that you
have. With you- that goes into
a little bit and that
California homeless Corning
financing councils goals which
include- a strategic plan
process. Call out our owner
rate. I'm at the- a bit more
detail happened that hand out-
but real quickly a couple
things on here. As a reminder
that the five million dollars
it was at night FY eighteen
ninety. All the three three C.
Wicks by next and so are we
recently received in your our
first Inori ports on this we
are as mentioned by lot as we
are in the midst of analyzing-
all of that road- information
right now but a couple things
we are seeing from that that I
think might be of interest- we
really are serving. Seeing is
spent across the state and what
we're seeing in. Front pockets.
I'm either around. Made of
approaches with the- number ski
thing that they had seen into
in their already and going to
scale- and reassessing
revamping systems and so and
hearing a lot about how and
spend specifically around
emergency shelter in capital
development we are seeing that
but I think specifically- how
that's- within the system of
communities is an interesting
piece of it as well I'm we are
also things I'm really at. Ste.
Investment concert every from
prevention. Andrew for how user
accessing homelessness services
I'm and I would also mention
and- you know you heard from
for mayor shaft or a really
strong commitment to housing
first we're seeing some really
great- commitments and proof
proof of concept X. explains
coming from the report. To be
analyzed. Is as so nice timely
hearing I want to give mega
call out for being city of a
was the very first application
raise the this year I think
that's probably wild mayor
shaft left to not be- they were
numbered unfortunately. Will
have to take second place here-
but that is for the forty two
years is a fifty county and
third cities I'm six. To be
spent although through June
after twenty. So just we- so
some delays I know that this is
been a conversation point in
receiving those applications
been hearing anecdotally that a
lot of that is because many
communities are in the midst
of. Conduct your point in time
counting so fully appreciate.
En en I'm a- on that in any way
while wait for apple. It just
makes double that harder in the
them. But we manage I. Does a
few different. That I do think
I'm- to out in addition to the
fact that counties are giving
this funding there are some
answers to. Allah this is the
final around but it does I will.
That were in the midst Kings
through he really intended to
be. Amer at our go quick and
this is our hope is for this
that there's a little bit more
of measurable goals to come out
of the applications. I'm really
thinking about have spending is
being spent in these different
buckets- in trying to.
Understand. How this piece of
the funding. A strong. Sort of
a commitment to regional
collaborations that we're
expecting to see in these
applications from he we put. In
a letter of support from all
going. Insurance the better
term but we- you know. Money
and CO Tienen really wanted be
how the three and the and
community I using their funds
in a co strategy and our our
looking forward to reviewing
game pieces of that. And I
think I'll stay for now and in
and time unless there's
addition one don't well wait
for all the panelists to go and
then we. And I am a professor
of medicine at UCSF and I
direct the UCSF center for
volatile populations. And the
UCSF homelessness and housing
initiative and I come to this
work as a physician and a
researcher who studies
homelessness- I don't need to
tell you that this is one of
the most pressing issues facing
California- that one the- only
one in nine. Americans live in
California we have the honor of
having one in four. People
experiencing homelessness in
this country like the rest of
the country homelessness in
California disproportionately
affects certain groups. A
predominately those who are
black American in indigenous
American. California also bears
the burden of having the
highest proportion of people
experiencing homelessness who
are on sheltered with about
sixty nine percent. Of home of
Californians living without
shelters most of the increases
that we've seen in the past two
years have been amongst those
living on sheltered. I think
it's important to say that the
increases in homelessness that
we've seen have not been due to
failures of the evidence based
policies that focus on ending
homelessness. Rather there due
to the structural conditions
that we face in California
predominantly the critical lack
of housing for extremely low
income Californians.
Intertwined with incomes
quality. Perhaps this. He did
it I tried to for us to per
people from and homelessness.
And it has created a problem
where it's hard for us to and
have people eggs as quickly as
possible. California right now
they're only twenty two units
housing that are available and
affordable for every a hundred
extremely low in. The house. So
extra. For those who class 30%
at the end. And we are the
second word state in the nation
on this metric. The primary
focus for solving this crisis
is passed to include a plan to
produce preserve and protect
housing that is affordable to
it for extreme low income
households. This is gonna take
dedicated efforts at every
level of government but if we
don't do it we're not going to
get there. For people who
experience from homelessness
and struggle with behavioral
health challenges like we were
talking about substance use and
mental health. You know what
the answer is and we have good
evidence it works we estimate
that about 20% of people who
experience homelessness fall
into this category probably at
any given time about half of
people who are experiencing it.
Are in this category because a
stay homeless longer permits
part of housing is simply
housing that is permanent it's
not a short term subsidy that's
affordable to extremely low
income renters. And that is
offered with voluntary support
of services things like case
management to have meant and
the like. For it to work as you
heard from mayor shaft it has
to be offered on a housing
first basis that means for this
to work the housing has to be
offered with out the
precondition. Friday or
precondition of engagement in
mental health care it can seem
counterintuitive but the
evidence. Stark and click. The
services have to be voluntary.
We know if we do this we can be
successful and I just wanna
point out that we've just read
it completing a dance to Clara
county. Downturn I. Am disabled
folks are chronically homeless
the most. Level of April to sit.
We found for of them we'll had
a hundred and four twenty four
units a permits part of housing
and super randomly selected who
would get it and- not. Of those
who were randomly selected to
get it eighty five percent.
Successfully house and they
spent over 90% of their nights
after the engaged and housing
house Ste. There were that. Red
this disabled population we
expect for populations were
slightly lower levels of
disability that the numbers are
even better. To create expand-
PSH we really need to create
the LA housing. It's good to
know that most of the services
could be paid through Medicaid
particularly with the waiver
that has been- suggested and
three secretary got. And so how
about the other 80% to get. How
really need to read efforts to.
From current and we also need
for on shortening at the set
when they do occur I've spoken
to some of you before now
research we found that half of
the single adults in this state
who are homeless or fifteen
older and 44% of them had never
been homeless before the age of
fifty but what we're finding is
that once they become homeless.
We'll hear from my colleague
Jamie some really- examples of
ways that we can intervene but
I will say that we know that
the key to early intervention.
Is to recognize quickly the
people who become homeless and
to have a flexible array of
services and support. There are
I'm they'll- yet. Stand in
space rapid housing. And
housing for spaces which is a
care package of benefits which
has time limit to subsidies
assistance of moving costs and
this is meant to stabilize sold.
And then you've heard about the
enormous success of the loss in
this flexible happen pool they
have used these funds for a
variety of purposes things like
he said. Subsidies assistance
with my an port woodland. Thank
and special good. Eight eight.
The key to sit seems to be an
flexibility. The other critical
area that you've heard about
today is homelessness
prevention but I want to say
about that is that we know we
the proper time getting to
police. Salt from entry. The
tree so in the for these
interventions to be successful
they have to be what we call
effective and efficient so
effective means they need to
work and know what seems to
work this is mostly from NY and
research out of New York is a
kind of flexible cage that
usually include some one time
it's usually up to a- hundred
dollars. Send pay back rent to
pay utilities and then other
services like legal services
for eviction Chen land decent
services and services increase
income. Allen Chau would you
rebel yet yeah. Our to get to
you what's in quite for great
just some in the nation and
what we for the prevent
targeting it to those at the
highest risk and allowing for
people to become homeless
meaning that if you tell me
that you're prevention pro
Allen became. I'm gonna tell
you you probably didn't target
to people who are likely to
become homeless anyway. Thank
you. This amounts. Thank you so
much good afternoon and thank
you for the opportunity to
share with you a day in the
life of a service and housing
provider in the bay area my
name is Jamie I'm on Sunday
executive director of bearing
unity services our backs for
short we have three hundred
forty staff who I consider
first responders in this work-
to help the on shelter cried as
an- backs. Thirty contract
between cities counties and the
state and feds. We know this
crisis must have a regional
approach and I promise I wrote
this before all the regional
questions so they will address
some of them. And a
collaborative approach. Two and
in this problem community based
organizations like back so my
colleagues in the room such as
St merry's abode swords to pop.
We all spend. 50% of our
organizational time navigating
and braiding these funds
together on behalf of all the
government entities it is an
utter waste of time that time
could be doubled up double in
the people we serve for backs
about half of our resources
from mental health and half of
them come from homeless and
resources. If we want to solve
homelessness we need. I usually
don't read my pages. Funds to
be directed regionally right
now we have a system that has
done a services on. Room and on
the other end that drought we
really focus on permanent
support of housing. What I've
looked. Wider thing we do St
out right now diners we
administer the coordinated
entry systems we housing
locator services in case
management we do permanent
support of housing and then of
course mental health services.
I've learned it is it's the
extreme it's the all or nothing
so you know we're really
focused on emergency services
will tend to be about 1020% of
the in house population need at
a time. And then on the other
hand of course PSH are. Out the
people in the middle of the
6280% of people in the middle
that and in our experience just
tend not to get anything
because of the way we've laid
out the system and many. They
really don't solve the problem
back says turned into this the
population three strategies
that demand there is permanent
housing resources tied to each
navigation bad. Like what
autumn I'm we've bought own
family home. As a permanent
today and the city of Oakland
we house five hundred fifteen
homeless seniors in Oakland and
a record time of seven months-
so it really goes to show that
there is availability out
there. We basically tested a
model of rather than on rights
that need space so one the
things. Has now models help. Us
okay nine months done people
don't were that way some need a
you or so people in the three
some need. For years of two one
Bucks some as a so we have now
to a of that. We need to design
model to under the true needs
of the person in front of us I
think we've learned that US.
This they are what. Group goes
to which of P. as I wrap up we
of them. Is really a- region as
run subsidies. When you really
talk about the- question I
think it's such a c<c.cyan>. My ex.</c>
In two city Okla and Berkeley.
It really and- all jump over
that city line and we have to
re Roger. Them to down that.
Killer city store. Shows I
think that's where the real
kind of in effect desk calls us
in older. And certainly was the
client and directions. Brown's
I'm think about each on per
needs some time of. Brown's
support we an in. Of my health.
Management serve how how's case
management we have come of up.
Of say okay this per and this.
So we to do a better job of
coordinating coordinating that.
Can we use made an entry we-
invested as a state and nay.
And the- entry so I know the
pet for. In where it and I know
where it it's has stray. I'm
but I think need to re look at
that hard and fast as we can.
To have these. Come down. And
the other thing I'll say is you
know we I I've time to many
people. There to stay out.
While they for voucher. So
they'll say I'm stay outside
for a years my fine comes up
the such eight voucher. That
shows us those golden ticket
system. Design has been flawed
and what we to do. Is really
get re. To that sixty per that
I talked about and then the
last thing I'll say in terms of
the challenges to a community
based organization on the
mental health side I think
there are some really good
questions. 50% of our staff
time is to satisfying cal
documentation dictated by rules
from the state of California.
That can be reduced to make.
Percent I cannot describe more
than saying every progress note
house to be scrutinized in
trouble read and before we're
sure that we'll get that
payment. That could than double
the population- so I think so
state rough. And of. Lost
reform mental health housing.
Would really. Bring double
resource to the streets and I'm
finally I am a firm believer of
the regional subsidy pool. Idea
yeah I think we've seen that
were done it ourselves we have
artificial. Than up market run
to rate speak as right now in
our- they may be tener twelve
fifteen us. After that same way
I'm. Lamb or got release the
first. Also back leukemia Bucks
a month though this age. That
where regional approach to
flexible so pool is real about
to real create. And then she
that the runs the rental does.
Out of go because the home up
and that were an and so just in
summer provide. Cry serve.
Rental subsidy that are new bay
based on the person math with
rap. Sir PSH for the 20% of are
so people needed. Let's stop
system of. PS of the in. Thank
you for much thank you we're
gonna open up to pay I know
miss because it. Is here to a
any question that we- we're
mayor Brough. Comments open it
to the committee for quite.
This for. So all. But what are
the key gaps that a way to
prioritize. What would make a
significant difference in
making the process work better
other choke points that we need
to address- and I've I've my
personal view is that at least
in my community we spend so
much attention on shelter. That
we don't and that's the most
controversial clearly a where
you put them- as as you
indicated in Los Angeles
however the same argument we
have the same situation I'm in
Kern. But but- king at the-
holistic. What what are the key
gaps that we need to be
addressing. I can start I think
he what we've realize is that a
large bloated group and then
that all are not being touched
anything Margo's. Sentiments
were saying so that the us in
our community 6% of people are
getting permanent supportive
housing in about twenty
fifteen. That need it. And
there's the shelter emergency
system where spending a lot of
focus which is of course- stand
a bill in terms of a sister. I
know who the 6280% are I do
their coordinator entreat
assessments- I know where they
school are in the world. And
all I have for the is. Eight
check back later on. Maybe is
very basic Robert house is very
prescribe on may be. Last month
deposit and if you find your
own place we help you get into
an city does individuals are
says but don't meet the
requirement to that they're not
severe enough in sit in that
sit in their situation to be
and that's the irony person
number for us in just
experienced person number four
thousand on the list to me
looks like person number two
hundred on the last and swear
on the margin. Right exactly so
it's really directing like that
whether it's a rental subsidy
pulling case management those
are the two interventions to
the to that. Son without having
to. Wait I would say so is that
as a resource to you or is that
a process it was a both. I
think it's I think it's both
the ads directing resources and
it's- eliminating some of the
policies that don't allow us to
serve the person in front of
us- based on just how the
policy. Works that. Yeah I
don't think anyone. I don't
think anyone would argue for
not investing in permits part
of housing for those most
disabled it's just that if you
haven't been how much. Time
meet those criteria. In many
parts this we offer very low.
And they may be able to be.
Much less and if they're not
they're gonna stay out there
for a long time and suffer a
lot so is there is there enough
service for that 60% or we
just. Is it apart it made or do
we need to expand that capacity
or do we have it. Or is that
capacity there and we're just
we just that case management
with lack. Right I think it is
a resource that you when you
have an interest to prior as to
where the greatest need as and
so you have a Cutie high need
population on the street need
part of housing that we is
that's why we- are issuing.
Proposition HHH bonds to
develop. Sufficient support of
housing then you have a large
and population on the street
that are trying to find
resources for those immediate
needs is a huge gap from the
city of LA- and so you're
looking at it I'm housing and
the folks in the middle. The
ones that have very tight that
means that they're not the your
prior to increase. Both those
and- patient level resources to
get at the people who may not
have the most immediate needs
but are developing them every
day like they will eventually
become. You they will go up
that list and they will qualify
for support housing. Is just to
be clear that the then the
solution is what. More
research. Resources shocking
okay to mention that Lake
County there's thousand people
with ulcers and- no place to go
yeah. So the source issue as
far as- the lack of affordable
housing. And so if it so we
have the thing available or
advocate job and for the
housing chair but is there that
is the housing there is that
the support housing there
that's part of the resources
that are needed we have we have
a housing affordability crisis
there's- issues we don't have
enough inventory and so rents
are rising we don't have enough
controls on rents I think. Is a
big part of it that housing is
getting developed in the proper.
Hi so that we rephrase my
question that if you were given
the resources what did you do.
To address 6080% if it's if
it's just if it the key is
resources what would you and-
sit down. With the strategy be.
I think that there is a
combination of investing in
affordable units that are just
affordable that don't require.
That on going subsidy as a
capital investment is
sufficient to. Just support a
lower rental rates so that
people who. Could it could pay
or rents in Florence were
available to them. We have more
unit. I do think there are
other policy related solutions
that have been- is starting to
be developed around where we
have- fourteen eighty two that
it will it will be. Hopefully
putting some. Restrictions on
on rising rents for people who
would then would not be losing
their housing in the first
place. But also- the city of LA
we've established. Other hello.
My Dorian can where for a
exchange for dance and projects
that are along those- state to
find hi transit areas where
they're getting big change for
that lower debt that higher
density that we are getting
affordable units covenanted
affordable you thanks James so
I think that it's a combination
more of a housing policy
conversation that needs to be
and also for those folks that
are in the middle to be able to
act. Even maybe even as with
subsidies. Things are are very
limited that's why you do see
people at the section eight
voucher who time out and are
not able to find a unit in a to
use that voucher and in the
amount of time you have to use
it we have and a big problem
with our overall housing market
and that's it. Another access
with. Finding units in the
private market I do think it's
getting harder and harder all
the time because that even that
supply or tapping out. And my
this guess last question if I
could address into you didn't I
wrote that you said that the
percent of time goes to medical
paperwork. And if we could.
Warm that and reduce it 210%
so. When you flush it out for
me in terms of when that
process is and how would. We
streamlined that how long do
you have. You know I. As long
as that is he'll he'll give
there's local groups- at least
in the bay and I'm sure this is
a state wide that have analyze
the regulation and the state
department of health care
services medi cal regulations
on the over reaching in and
Berman some documentation that-
very specific like right now as
an example- staff person has to
write a personal by the minute
of service if I go out and I'm
working with someone that's
homeless currency mental health
so stop symptoms. And I do a
fourteen minute conversation I
have to write. Top of page note
that talks through it all for
that fourteen minutes if I want
to be sure that it won't get
disallowed and so that. SO
literally our staff 50% of
their time is documentation 50%
is no writing or and you know
you that's the constant dancing
games so I'd be happy to offer
like all those. Certainly who
would like to look at me so
it's actual paper at youth fax
over to or is it dead on. That
documentation of this service
to then render the bill into
than get paid. Okay so it up
said H. M. and some ways he if
you get the lower to like one
page or a monthly it says a
sentence yeah verses a page
literally staff para
professionals all the way up
to. The clinicians have right
you know a substantial note to
get paid for that okay why Sir
I certainly want to explore
that I want to get too much.
Thanks very much thank you. So
I have a- question that's
specific because to the issue
of- how well we are- actually
collaborating on a regional
basis and whether or not
there's room for improvement-
and the question relates to-
cities that are nine he
eligible this I think is most
relevant to the- county of LA
but it- in the first. In the
proposed funding allocation- is
there room for non heap
eligible cities to receive
funding because we have an on
going issue in the city and a
Monica where- they're not.
Receiving funding for a program
that has demonstrated multi
disciplinary team program that
has demonstrated positive
results- in the going to have
to- and that program in June if
they don't receive funding. The
perhaps Mister Ramirez you
might surpass thanks to answer
that well I mean we don't love
you you mentioned he funding
right- I think that's where the
well I mean I think- frankly
the jurisdiction is looking for
any possible Avenue to continue
this program yeah eight. Yeah
turn down there applique. I'm
not aware I to push on this no
no worries I'm not a familiar
with the application that was
private that's one of our
challenges in LA county is that.
You know there's eighty seven
other cities besides. City well.
Yeah Palm Beach Pasadena
Glendale are their own
consumers can of care so they
do get funding but for the
other cities- that's been our
biggest challenge we invest a
lot of time trying to- get them
as part. From our measure
explains that I that I. On this.
Of we provided cities the opera.
Up apply for around fifteen
million dollars worth of. No
we're was. But I know it's not
enough and the city's- you know
a lot of them staff to even-
fellow programs and several
other cities believe do it the
bill. There's no money I'm for
you something cities to their
own. But so projects like that
or or programs that you
mentioned up for you based on
what you told me would probably
would have. I'm qualified for
whatever funding grants that we
were providing cities- a couple
years ago- dot funding and as I
believe in the next come next
coming fiscal year. Will be we
will be looking at- musing more
H. P. to provide additional
funding to cities that are we
are we getting funding but also
on. These an regional council
of governments with dean in the
future so that pro innovative
programs like this- that you
mentioned- would get funded-
either directly to the city or
through a council of
government- kind of- function.
I'd be happy to talk to you
more about this but hopefully-
these the kind of issues that-
can be resolved before the
programs and- the folks who
were responsible for carrying
them out- go elsewhere and then
starting it up against nearly
impossible I will I will- get
the message to my director who-
very well. Cell so I will.
Thank you. Mr person thank all
panelists for your very concise
presentations we could probably
talk for hours on this the
futures however questions of
these are more request
information but- from the
geographic jurisdictions that
were that are here I asked-
both mayor shaft mayor Liccardo
if you it has if they had a
sense of a needs assessment and
how much would it cost their
their cities in the region's to
address homelessness I know LA
city and county you're
suggesting a two billion
dollar. Annual appropriation do
you have a needs assessment and
I'd love I know you're working
on those numbers but we'd love
is more of a request for
information when you get those
numbers love to get them yeah
they also the same to San
Francisco I have a sense of the
numbers but love to get that we
think we need more money spent
just. Bye bye wondering where
you are with your analysis.
Assemblymember Chiu thanks for
the question just wanted to
point out that- the nine bay
area counties are actually
working to. Together under the
leadership of a nonprofit
called home base. To the things
that we're doing is to. Being a
systems map of all services
available to people
experiencing homelessness in
that area will then used.
Develop a gap analysis. To
deter. Where there are. Someone
much it would cost to fill
those. We're also working to
legal over each of my a systems
together into one single
system- so that were at least
able to share information about
people who are traveling from
county to county seeking
services. So some of this work
is already in progress and a
since I have the Mike also just
wanted to point out that all
echo- my colleagues and mayor
shaft on the car does concerns
about creating- another level
of bureaucracy this regional
administrator there is
actually. A lot of work
happening at the regional level
I think this goods state. To
take steps to mandate- and to
take some leadership on budget
having regional collaborations
but I don't think adding
another another layer into this
funding is a particularly good
idea. Because a lot of work
actually already happening. I
would just on that point or- of
benefits. Thank missed amounts
to you it also suggested there.
There are definitely some
benefits to regional work but
it seems. You know the issue of
whether we need an entire layer
of a regional bureaucracy. I
think is a very open question
for us in the legislature so.
Would love protect the after
this here if you want to email
us. We are you think. What you
think we need to do to make
sure that the regional
conversations are happening-
and if not a- regional entity
managing that. How else should
we structure to ensure those
conversations occur. I'm
totally deaf conversation.
About silos. We know it's one
it's easy to kind of focus on.
Homelessness as it happens but
there are many other systems
are healthcare system. Our
control justice system our
education system our foster
care system. Where breakdowns
those systems are leading
Thomas as- we also know there
expenditures a monies in those.
Their policy renew. That if
they were better spent could
help reduce homelessness. One
in. If you of advice to us on
how do we and sent. Other
systems outside of the housing
and homelessness system. To
incent these other policy
Salas. Work better with those
of you. On the front lines of
addressing homelessness. To do
this is it I passed a bill
couple years ago the governor
brown side- push the
conversation Harper met a
chronically- clinically was.
Six seven eight different
policy us. I can sure just a
little I think the cross
systems approaches what I also
call regionalization so I it
backs our organization has a
contract with the probation
department for maybe a half a
million dollars to use that as
a flexible spending subsidy
pull to house people on
probation yeah so that's that
was my kind of ultimate plane
to is that set the silo we had
that can be braided together so
if you're looking at real
supply. All kind of spending
policy and I need
regionalization based on the
kind of intricacies of each Gen.
I wouldn't have to say well let
me check this box for this
individual on a me to access
this part of money for this.
Effort and it would be just
really- through policy
requiring you know whether it's
the criminal justice system the
and I think there's I think the
Senate to the well as here
right now and we're all going
towards the same goal but-
where what it feels like in is
on the streets right now is.
There is you know the silos are
alive and well and it's
creating that the person in
front us to jump through so
many more hoops to house them
and so. I am a large proponent
of regionalization and will
definitely email thoughts
because I at least where I sit-
we do not have regionalization
we have great partnerships and
relationships of talking to one
another our cities and counties
are amazing. Awesome and what
if it what it is on the streets
for us- we- do not have the
regional approach. Any other
comments on that so excuse me
one second sorry I did
apologize because I need to go
I apologize for not be able to
finish the remainder the
hearing but Mister bloom is
going to be- that turned the
gavel over to Mr bloom and he's
gonna finish. So appreciate
that they at thank you again to
all the- panelists for coming
today. Up you for that and in
and I very much would welcome
any thoughts that you would
have on. How do we and sent the
breakdown of silos how do we
had sent- the right
conversations to happen in this
kind of regional. Place my
perspective- we have to devote
as I've said before I think a
much larger fraction of our
budget around a permanent
source of funding. The grub
with homelessness but I suspect
we could probably crap parts of
different budgets. Again from
education. Health criminal.
Except in an and if we have a-
swimming. In at some point
obviously want to talk to the
governor's office and
administration about that if
you have any comments on that
yeah I would just say so as
part of the- Canadian financing
counsel. For a lot of that is
has re up till recently been
focused on just the funding
sources are using far
homelessness specifically I
think we've- in. Since I am I
don't think I'm selling him out
but I'm the- it. Voters is arm.
Federal I an on homelessness
has been helping us through
what a state to teach I am a
look like- and I think some of
what that look like having had
experience of a level is not
just thinking about the funding
streams we have but so. How are
the wraparound services being
best use how are we sort of
acknowledging where folks are
are accessing different service
were already providing at the
state level and where might
those folks come in
conversations it's something
we're very much looking up. As
at about what check plan for
the council the click straight
and one final. The Amman's what
you said around the bureaucracy
that leads to fifty percent.
Staff waste time. Up super
interested that as well and- I
would just say my colleague
Mister Fung this might be a
place for some bipartisan.
Conversations of how we
addresses because that's-
outrageous. I think all have an
interest in. Streamlining that
and I think. Just say that is
part of I think many natural
hesitance around again at.
Another level of bureaucracy.
When you have three years of
one time for. Each year creates
a new set of requirements with
players. At some point. A
little bit character. It's not
supposed to be so- low love
love come in that area and like
Mr ting I. Have that I need to
be out at five. But look for to
an ongoing conversation. Thank
the for your engagement on this
thank you. I'm gonna make one
other point if I could to your
question in a need. To leave us
a moment Chiu but I want to
point out that between two
thousand and five two thousand
and fifteen. Changed time is
that redevelopment agencies one
away and that of state
investment in affordable
housing- was reduced
significantly a lot of what
we're talking about in the
risen to brand funding together
and to be more efficient and
I'm a huge support court did
and better systems but at the
end of the day. All is. Right a
resource that everybody needs
there's not enough of so I
really hope that the state will
focus strongly on the need for
more housing because at the end
of the day we're not going to
be a we can have the best
systems in the most rated well
find systems in the world but
if there's not a housing the
end of the day this is gonna
can. AB one. And also a point
out that we're talking about.
And also want to point out that
during in 18322% of all
Americans. Or home 2% of
Americans were nineteen thirty
two by nineteen sixty that was
zero. That was zero and that
this the solution is so in
reach amended to work on time
in the solution so in which
were not. Really need to focus
on housing at the state level.
Let us locally focus on how
we're going to collaborate
better we need to and have to
do a better job and we're we're
working on it we hope that the
state will really focus in on
what I know assemblyman Chiu
you. I was very hot there needs
to be more housing read. As we
just. Leadership in our city on
that and I could not agree with
you more- I. Stuck my
colleagues know benefit of a
broken record for my. Four
should we lost almost two
billion dollars a year. That we
used to test and- housing. And
over ten years dot spin awful
lot of money and I think that's
the scale that we need to reply
back to the- to the since our
but it's gonna take. A bigger
conversation the legislature
it's very difficult to talk
about increasing funding beyond
the five. Six seven hundred
fifty million dollars talking
about. So for to figure out how
we build that consensus on
making that. Thank you. Thank
you the only thing I would add
is that- at the loss of
redevelopment as a harsh is it
what does only exacerbate.
Portable housing that's been
produced over the last forty
years or so- so this is a long
standing problem- redevelopment
kind of filled at the breach to
a certain ex. Now we have that
and- we certainly knew the duty
to find a way to replace that
very important funding source.
So with that on on of. A German
the tank I would like to thank
each of our presenters
panelists- for presentations
we're going to move on now to
public comment I hope that some
of you have stuck around this
hearing is gone- admirably
longer than- any of us sent to
pay thank of the does town
portent this issue as I'm gonna
ask- all read the name talk.
The each of the do you get
public time got my- set up by a
over here the under. Your
comments limited to approx one
minute please say real you've
been a long time and you
probably have more than a
minute's worth of comments- but
we do need to move this along
so- let me. Paul several names
at a time it feels for. With
any. Followed by Tom bay
Sherilyn add. And Wesley saver.
Okay that's regrettable- Cheryl
and Adam is. Did you put in a
check. Okay come on down. A lot
for you the services welcome.
Marty Regan Republic funding
for larger street youth
services of we just want to
thank you for this. This panel.
Say they he been have. You can
bet. Knowing there's if there's
Senate side in those funding
were like twenty intervening
with homeless youth now
prevents future chronic
homeless chronically homeless
adults we can prevent more
families from becoming homeless
if we can interview with you
how are we need on investments
a and a wide array of housing
options including. These
limited rubbery housing options
thank. You very much. Wesley's.
Afternoon assembly members echo
the statements from. Select per
hosting in here prioritize we
experience. What's the same
policy and center for. The
recent ones in such as he have
happy the about the is yours
youth almost among local teams
of care and we are hopeful this
one time investment they're not
adequate to make meeting
production. Problem our
traditional continuum's of care
have. Been oriented toward
address homelessness among the
adult popular since there's-
now that. Hi the issue under K.
in can. Pretty when it comes to
down to find home youth I such
we respectfully request that
the budget as in the past two
years include a specific you
set aside op fortunate to the
homeless youth. Next we have
Miguel Carnera I apologize if I
mispronounce your names
Schering. Enhanced the shop
sorry please. One is
homelessness for over twenty
six you saw- so what when did
you know when you can seven
hundred fifty millions I really
to be pushed into onto not no
one thought. That the one for
over the this is important
because they can be them but I
is up on in homeless people.
About how and anything people
needs but out one one thing
though when I. Mention this is
a really important on this
important do guys a hello is
they- spend. When I stand up.
About eleven I don't you choose
a lower the in homelessness if
you anything I fatherless and
children's and I think it we
have a big number homeless uses
a home business for example in
some Francisco we are over.
I'll but the thought understand
is on his way. So NHL we need
them doesn't final I want to
make is or this is how to leave
when they the house winner in
the- subsidies temp voice.
Montel as we need a housing.
She has as a point thank you so
much thank you very Sharon
cornu. Followed by Alan Cooper
Steve fish often Anna Johnson
please Sherrin Quinlan the
executive director at Saint
Mary's center a senior center
at. With a community of hope
healing and justice in west
Oakland we provide transitional
how. See winter shelter and are
getting ready to be. Support it.
I want to echo the comments.
JBL months of from back as well
as our mayor mayor shaft but
also point out to you that we
are creating. Permanent system
to deal with a permanent crisis
and the for any of us for many
years the hope was that limited
duration intervention would
solve the issue of home. Family
an individual. Tiny we need to
wreck as this is a permanent
part. Aye collective life going
forward based on changes in our
housing market as well as in a
quote. Courage committee
through the budget per. Okay
sustainable source funding
through groups on the ground
fighting direct services and
leading innovation thank you.
Much Dr Alan Cooper Steve fish
and Johnson and Argo Daschle.
Stock I. Afternoon good
afternoon my name is Anna John
with Byrne advocates for youth
I am here to just share our
things for the 5% satisfied
that went into the heap funding
in the 8% satisfied that went
into the half funding that was
dedicated to address youth
homelessness specifically this
was a first time investment of
the federal government does not
invest directly into use. A
Grammy and we do know that you
are more vulnerable to
victimization when they are
homeless. They lose all of
their possessions they take a
step back in school and there
isn't any other dedicated
source of funding. To our youth
so it's so important that this
year's budget investment does
include a ten percent set aside
for our use based on the point
time counts thank you. Thank
you very much. Dr Cooper. Right
here Steve but if. Thank you I
hope this is being written up
somewhere in a fascinating.
It's actually matter fact I'm
was the state support of
housing coalition we're focused
on permanent support housing
for people with serious mental
illness. And that's something
we're- we're really focused on
that but it relates a lot to
other things you're talking
about I think. One thing I hope
doesn't disappear if the- if
the governor's proposal doesn't
really get incorporated the
ways proposed at this time is
that part of that was to be
able to subsidize board care
homes to prevent homelessness.
You know because if they go
they're going out of business
if they go out of business
they're gone- you know some
cities San Francisco to good
example only because he's doing
some stuff that way to or
trying to figure out how to
stop that. And you know maybe
it didn't to be a part. Well we
got a with. Because it's gone
will. And so open that that
part. Was Cervantes. This
process. Thank you Margot down.
Molly and does an early. I'm no
dash and I'm with the national
lines on mental illness the
East Bay affiliate and also
with the East Bay supportive
housing collaborative that
Steve just mentioned. Assembly
member bloom I heard you say
something about reservation. In
this seven hundred and fifty
million dollars for a set aside
for Borden cares and I would
like to know more about your
reservation but we were very
lifted in our hearts to hear
that there was some attention
to stabilizing the license. Do
emphasize the license and cares
so many people including young
people of who descend into the-
horrors of psychosis need the
stabilization bad a board and
care can five hello. Boarding
talking about. Management
vicious food mental stimulation
these are the things that help
people gain recovery and get on
their feet when we put people
in just old boarding houses
shelters we're going to recycle
them again and again through
fifty one fifties and to the
streets thank you- we do hope
for that thank thank you for
your comment and tap my comment
about for care fund it is. A
essentially has to do with
whether or not it might be
better to have a funding source
outside of the seven hundred
fifty million since- many
people- important care homes
are potential potentially going
to become homeless but there
are many more- who will and
there's just the confluence of
interested the bank. Might make
it better to have a separate
funding source for that kind of
our badly in agreement about
the importance of the issue and
it is shipped csus can. Did you.
Want me to read your comment or
did you want. We have only and-
where to please give that AA.
I'm Erik are fun to a yeah
health the people that suffer
with men health connection and
print out each service.
Approach in our research that
can help target those that
population because that
population I'd I also happen
this in that scene I recycling
through homelessness and it
becomes like a to site to
families. Of that something
that I really want to stress is
to- maybe provide. Five in both
of those. This is an meant how
ready. Since I can be needs I.
And the fact thank you and to
you didn't identify yourself
are you Maria Molly Molly okay
on behalf of Natalie Natalie
not hearing. Great thank you
very much and- Maria Menendez.
Regan. Welcome hi welcome thank
you very much- I wanted to
express our thanks and
gratitude for the state's
support and thought partnership
my name is market back allowing
the policy director at compass
family services here in San
Francisco- I wanted to echo
the- the partners we need. I'm
going to spending. And without
additional of bureaucracy the
money is. Flowing there's a the
regulations that the prevent us
from help the person right in
front of us now- we also need
to change the public
conversation around cleaning
the streets I we need to put
people. And complaints about
the sidewalks should not be the
primary engines power almost
systems. What we need to look
beyond this there are a lot of
fan that are doubled up in
overcrowded and sub housing
conditions and they're
basically living and functional
sheltered homelessness states
and the regulations are and
always capturing- those living
situations as homelessness-
there the families are very
precariously house across the
state the pic counts count
about fourteen thousand
children. Oldest data so much
for over. Almost us statewide
has increased on by more than
20% over the past couple of
years so- I think the point
here is that homelessness and
Pete's children intellectual
social emotional and physical
development- and children who
are homeless are five times
more likely to become homeless
homeless as adults so we make
sure that are meant our
intervention now targeted
antenna third. Homelessness is
an provide the future almost.
Of our- thank you could wrap up
here thank you very much Choi.
Liliana bonds. Hi hi I'm
nervous but my name is Donna
lawns in Asia of all in at the
homes I have I will speak for
myself and for other young
women like me I feel like I've
been senior everybody talk
about making decisions about
people like me and my community
but I'm actually person that
has been through it and I feel
like I had been homeless for
over four years I have two
children I'm twenty years old-
I had a homeless when I was
sixteen I can not the services
I thought we need continuing of
money coming in but we all.
Hold these these- I can you.
Into your and- like for me I
will homeless and I was proud.
I could not get into a shelter
it was so hard for me. I can
get into a temporary shelter I
want to the access points I
want to compass I want to
everywhere I needed to go. But
because I didn't. That category
of looking homeless. And sleep
my car but because I wasn't
physically on. I looked I get
prioritize and I feel like.
That's not ext. Especially when
you're pregnant and you don't
have no other sources used to
prioritize. And I thought they
should. Fix the way that this
the system is because I know
even with subsidies subsidies
are temporary that is just a
cycle putting people back into
homelessness. And that's
unacceptable you don't see when
you get a subsidy and is
pushing people farther out so
that's what people want to lay-
they're going to Stockton they
want all these places. You can
afford to the city California's
is so expensive. In one
sentence in its absurd there's
not enough money that's a
different flowing through your
senses are so much money. And
it's like how can you guys say
or entry a pregnant woman like
that and in people families.
Like I understand it is a big
thing I live here in the
tenderloin. Like the mental
health issues. Sources to the
access. I did. It will get. It
was so hard I to go to the high
team I think goal his ex as the
help me I had to advocate for
myself at a push muscle to meet
the exact director if you could
please wrap up please- but I
just want to see more people in
the community and trying to
help. To stabilize housing
especially from. It's not just
people with mental health
issues so many young women and
children and youth and families
homeless street it is
unacceptable especially in the
city that we live in the house
so much more thank thank you
very much for your comment and
our last. Year's Tyler I'm
sorry I can't make out the last
name Tyler. Hi in the without
county behavior how to act as a-
welcome. Group my name so
couple things I'd like to I'm
the for on how. And housing
that we have in here in
California- but we'd like to
advocate to have- a focus on
prevention and early
intervention- individuals
experiencing homelessness- we
know that the longer end of.
Days on the streets and
experiences the trauma of the
streets that the more likely
they are to develop or
exacerbated by here for of can.
And the more expensive they are
going to be to end up receiving
treatment and to stabilize
them. Arm we'd like to be
supportive of you going to the
existing model that was under
half for funding for cities
counties and it CEO sees rather
than this you know. Regional
administrator bottle arm
there's a lot of things that
are under five. I'm were also
supportive of. Assembly member
bloom what you mentioned I've I
the crisis aborted. Our losing
them today have a separate
propose. To have them in. A
separate pot of funding where
will it be concerned about if
that money slice three
different ways between housing
development. I'm rental
subsidies and boarding cares
that we may continue to lose
warning cares and they will not
be stabilized as that's a very
critical- component of care and
housing for our population and
for others with disabilities.
So thank you for the time.
Thank you very much for
comments- and applause for
everyone- especially- those of.
You who are still here and
stuck it out for the whole
meeting. Congratulations to you
it's good that we took the time
that we- debt to consider. This
important issue this is an
issue that- across the state
our constituents are tell us-
is their number one concern and
I. Level and- level we're not
seriously that's why we have
this hearing today and to thank
you all for participating.